Ich habe gerade festgestellt, mein Headset ist total verglodet.
Aber warum wusste das man mal hier oben drüber, das ist jetzt hier unten drunter, ah ok, nice.
Huge Entknotungs Skills am Start, habe ich von den Pfadfindern gelernt früher, ich war
mal bei den Pfadfindern, fast irgendwie acht Jahre lang oder so, ich habe noch nie einen
Pfad gefunden, ich weiß bis heute nicht warum die so heißen ehrlich gesagt, aber ich kann
Zelte aufbauen seitdem ich da war, Huge Survival Skills, kann Zelte aufbauen und Stockbrot
über dem Feuer grillen, das wars glaube ich was ich daher kann, wird das Youtube Video
mit dem Titel nee, nope, nope Champing, ganz schön heiß hier, das ist 26 Grad, die Malallage
einschalten, exquisite, Q-Korne am Start, alter 23 Monat, das ist ja massive falscher Knopf,
Alter, kann ich mal richtig, WTF, ich brauche, wo ist er denn, ist mein Board verrutscht,
wo ist mein, wo ist mein, ah, das stimmt doch alles, alles richtig, fast zwei Jahre, fast
zwei Jahre, Big Brain ja, aber ab zwei Jahre ist ja quasi schon Elevenhead angesagt, das
passt gar nicht mehr alles rein, RGB, Headset, Leak, nee, what, nein, ich habe übrigens
einen neuen Code, falls euch das aufgefallen ist, guckt mal hier, neuen Code, ich habe
einen neuen Code, ist das ein richtiges X, das ist doch kein richtiges X oder, hat das
jemand mal ausprobiert ob das funktioniert, was ich hier geschrieben habe, ist das ein
X, ist das ein richtiges X, okay, X, he, what the, was ist das, ich glaube das sieht einfach
nur zwischen den Zahlen so kacke aus, he, wait a minute, what the, das ist ein Chrome
Feature, das ist Massive Chrome Feature oder irgendwie sowas, guckt euch das mal an, oder
ist das mein Font, was ist das, was ist das, was ist das für ein Font, MonkaS, die Default
Twitch, ernsthaft, okay, 4x4, so nicht, aber wenn ich es jetzt hier dazwischen mache, schon,
okay das ist ganz schön fail, wusste ich gar nicht, nee, man lernt nicht aus hier, Twitch,
Twitch Font, okay, aber das ist normales X Leute, Twitch ist bloß denkt, Twitch ist
schlauer als wir, die müssen mitdenken, aus dem Pfeil, Moment, Moment, wenn aus dem Pfeil
sowas wird, wird dann auch sowas, ah nee, nee, Programmierstelle können die nicht,
die können nur sowas, was kann der Twitch, was kann der Twitch Font noch, den da, irgendwie
sowas, nee, ja das geht, ja das dachte ich, dass die so, aber der Twitch Font hat sowas
nicht, wenn die, was ist denn DTM, achso, ist das Auto, Autorennstells, ich bin mal
nicht, Autorennstells, guck ich nicht, 4x4 geht nicht, du musst es doppelschreiben, guck
mal, so gehts auch nicht, ja wenn du das X dann löscht, dann gehts wieder, bei dir
ist es jetzt auch mit dem, mit dem Mal, was passiert denn bei 4x4, machts dann auch irgendwas,
nee, durch oder so, okay der Font ist echt inkonsistent, keine Ahnung, weil wenn man
schon durch macht, dann hätte man eine richtig Big Brain Mathematiker Schreibweise schreiben
können, sondern einfach so in der Mitte, wisst ihr so, so, so, gibt es so ein Zeichen
überhaupt auf der Tastatur, so einen horizontalen Strich, quasi so und dann die Zahlen oben
drüber und drunter, echt, das hat sich geändert, bitte minute, tatsächlich, pock, achja es
gibt ein neues E-Mode, guck mal, wir haben ein neues E-Mode, wupp, Pet2, Mathef, Dankeschön
für die 10 Monate, huge subscription hier und NRAA mit Reis, NRA, Nummer 44 ist es
mit Reis, kann auch sein, ist es Leadspeak oder ist es Nummer 44, man weiß es nicht
so genau, aber Dankeschön für die ganzen Subs Leute, Nummer 44 mit Reis, Nummer 44,
das ist China-Mann-Bestellung, also Leute, was wir heute machen ist folgendes, wir gucken
uns mal von Anfang an an, nicht nur wie man einen Linux-Server einrichtet, das haben wir
jetzt ja glaube ich oft genug gemacht, sondern wir gucken uns auch mal die Sachen an drum
rum, also sprich welches Betriebssystem nimmt man am besten, gibt ja mittlerweile nicht
mehr so viel Auswahl, seitdem CentOS es nicht mehr gibt, er hält sich ja in Grenzen, ja
dann gucken wir wie man das unter Windows, unter Linux das einrichtet, dass man beispielsweise
sich mal einen ordentlichen SSH Key generiert, wir fangen einfach mal von vorne an und während
wir das Ganze machen, klicke ich ein bisschen in der Hetzner Cloud rum, damit sich das auch
lohnt, dass sie den Stream sponsoren können, Rocky Linux, ja Rocky Linux hab ich noch nie
im Einsatz gehabt ehrlich gesagt, weiß gar nicht ob das mittlerweile fertig ist, sodass
man es benutzen kann, wann kommt Kubernetes-Session mit CI, CD über RIT, weiß ich nicht, dazu
bräuchte ich erstmal irgendeinen Kubernetes-Cluster oder was Lokales, aber das ist auch doof,
was das gesehen, nee, say hi to Microsoft's own Linux CBL, was für Dinger, was ist denn
ein CBL, ich mach schon eine Weile Linux, ich hab keine Ahnung, was ist ein CBL, ah
Cannabis, ok, verstehe, was hat das damit zu tun, Vapenation, Common Base Linux, ach
so, das ist quasi sowas wie ein eigenes Image, jetzt sagt das doch mal einer, wo soll ich
zum, das ist das für Common Base, reine Güte, ja gut, ich glaub nicht, dass das irgendjemand
braucht, außer vielleicht, wenn du in Azure irgendwelche Container-Stalls machen willst
und kein Blockast auf Ubuntu, ach, ich weiß nicht, mal gucken, mal gucken, Alex Vegan,
Huge Prime Sub, Massive, den haben wir sonst noch, ich hab's komplett übersehen hier
wieder alles, dann würd ich noch, dann würd ich mehr Geld bekommen, so für die eigenen
Verwendungen, wobei ich weiß gar nicht, bekommt man als Dozent viel Geld, wahrscheinlich,
aber kommt ja in unserem Bildungssystem selten viel Geld, deswegen haben wir da zum größten
Teil ja auch nur Noobs, außer auf höchstem Level, da dann wieder nicht, ok, also, ich
zeig euch, es ist Basic Knowledge, ja, übrigens, soll ich euch mal was zeigen, ich fand mich
letztens voll lustig, ja, oh Moment, ich muss euch mal kurz ausmachen, ich weiß nicht, in
welchem Fenster ich Discord aufgemacht hab, Moment, Bild ist gleich wieder da, ich muss
so gucken, dass ich nicht im falschen Channel oder im falschen Fenster Discord aufgemacht
hab, man weiß, man weiß ja nie, ja, so, alles klar, sag, so, Moment, ich mein, gut Chat,
ich fand mich letztens total lustig, mit dem Bild hier, ok, ich gab zu, das ist ein bisschen
Dead Joke, aber ich fand, ich fand mich total lustig mit dem Bild, ich hab nämlich geguckt
nach Stellenanzeigen für das nächste Video und da hab ich gesehen, Frestnap sucht einen
Agile Coach und da hab ich mir gedacht, der beste Agile Coach dürfte doch Chico sein,
ich geb zu, guck mal, neues Emote wird benutzt, ja, ja, schon ein bisschen Dead Joke, ich
fand es nicht, was hältst du vom neuen Battlefield Modus, es ist ja kein Modus im eigentlichen
Sinn, das ist ja ein bisschen Content vom Hersteller, gut, könnte man eigener Modus
nennen, aber hauptsächlich was zum selberbauen, oder ja, ich weiß, was du meinst, ja, ich
find, das ist ne gute Idee, leider gehts mir noch nicht weit genug, aber vielleicht kommt
ja noch was, ich hab ja drauf gehofft, dass es ein Map Editor ist, ja, ja, man kanns ja
mal probieren, ne, so, was wollt ich euch denn jetzt zeigen, genau, ich mach mal kurz
hier mein Lidox an, also, einmal das Pricing muss ich aufmachen und dann zeig ich euch
mal was, was wir jetzt machen, wo ist das Pricing, so, Firefox, ja, du hast alle Level
E-Modes gesammelt, steht jetzt da, Poggers, also wir nehmen heute nicht die fetten Kisten,
die 321 Euro im Monat kosten, sondern wir nehmen tatsächlich auch mal die bisschen
kleineren, dass man das auch besser auf seinen eigenen Kram übertragen kann, ne, ich glaub
320 Euro im Monat ist minimal über dem Budget, was die meisten Leute im privaten Umfeld
so haben für Lidox Kisten, wir können uns auch noch ne fettere in der Server Auktion
kaufen, so, zumindest worauf ich raus will, ist Musik ein bisschen laut oder, ne, passt,
Musiklautstärke ist gut, ich glaub ich kanns in Ticken, Ticken, Tickenleiser machen,
das Mario Kart Zeug ist immer laut, so exquisite, war es schon jemals interessant im Stream,
Chat, jetzt mal ernsthaft, das kommt hier doch eigentlich nicht vor, es mag vielleicht
mal ab und zu mal Dinger geben, es mag vielleicht mal ab und zu mal Dinger geben, die man sich
angucken kann, aber in der Regel ist ja nie interessant, sowas machen wir hier nicht,
ne, also folgendes, ich erzähl euch jetzt mal was, was wir machen, also wir machen wirklich,
wir machen wirklich Basic, wir gucken uns erstmal an, was es für Lidox Systeme so gibt, also
Server technisch, und dann gucken wir uns an, wie man, wisst ihr was, ich hab die Idee,
wir benutzen Windows 11, wir machen das richtig, richtig Bleeding Edge, äh, wir benutzen Windows
11, warte mal, was ist denn hier das Windows 11, wo wir letztens was eingerechnet haben,
das da, da bin ich mal gespannt, wahrscheinlich geht die Hälfte damit nicht, wie kein Windows
11 Leute, warum nicht, warum, ich könnte es auch Remote über Stadia machen, also jetzt
stellt euch mal nicht so an mit Windows 11, also es geht immer schlimmer, Windows 11
geht auch auf den Raspberry Pi, ja, das müsste gehen, Windows 10 geht ja auch, oh nein, close,
was, your Microsoft account requires attention, warum, haben sie festgestellt, dass es ein
Fake Account ist, sag bloß, ne, oder auch nicht, ja was denn jetzt, Update, Update, ne,
ich will, Alter, One Try, was weiß ich, mein Passwort doch nicht mehr, ok, wir machen das
vielleicht doch nicht unter Windows 11, Windows Update, ja, gib mir Updates please, ja, mach
doch Updates, ich brauch doch gar nichts, alles gut, so, haben wir Windows Terminal installiert,
das ist das wichtigste, wir sind schon so modern, dass wir das heute unter Windows 11 machen,
zumindest die, die, so bescheuert, so bescheuerten Usernamen hatten, aber ok, so, also Leute,
ihr könnt es euch überlegen, wir brauchen hier eine kleine Seite, um den Server dann
am Endeffekt auch einzurichten über SSH, also, wollen wir das von Linux aus machen
oder wollen wir das von Windows aus machen, realistischer ist es das mal von Windows aus
zu zeigen, wir können das, wie gesagt, von Windows 11 bietet sich jetzt an, weil ich
ne Windows 11 VM hab, der Vorteil ist, das von Windows aus zu machen, die meisten Leute
benutzen, benutzen halt Windows, Windows 98, Windows 98, hab ich glaube, hab ich noch
die Windows 98, das geht sogar von Windows 98 aus, aber dann müssen wir Putty verwenden
und Windows und Putty ist Paynes Champ, nee, ich glaub, wir haben, wir können, wir können,
Leute, wir können auch Dings verwenden, wir können Mobuntu verwenden als Client, wenn
es euch lieber ist, das hatten wir auch schon ne Weile nicht mehr an, Terraform mit Hetzener
Cloud, wir wollen es jetzt erstmal zum Einsteigen nicht übertreiben, wir machen das so, dass
der Sache in jeder folgen kann, hoff ich mal, Cute4M ist am Start, die können wir auch
nehmen, wir wechseln, wir wechseln einfach ab, zwischendurch, richtiger Sellout Stream,
ja, dieser Stream, falls ihr es noch nicht gesehen habt, ich muss mal eine VM ausmachen,
das ist ein bisschen, ich hab zwar 32G RAM, aber wenn ich meinen VMs immer 16G RAM gebe,
dann ist irgendwann auch mal Schluss, also folgendermaßen, was wir jetzt machen ist,
ich geh erstmal Disclaimer, dieser Stream ist gesponsort, die Musik ist richtig poggers,
aber auch nicht mehr wie die letzten Streams, wo ich mich mit diesem Thema beschäftigt
hab, wenn ihr auf der Suche seid nach nem Hostinganbieter und euch mal mit, wo hab ich
hier stehen, euch mit 20€ Startguthaben eindecken wollt, dann könnt ihr euch Behzener Cloud
registrieren und meinen Code eingeben, das ganze geht bis Ende des Jahres, ich weiß
nicht wie lange das Guthaben gültig ist, wann das verfällt, aber es reicht auf jeden
Fall ein paar Monate, weil das gute ist, ihr könnt beispielsweise für 20€ Startguthaben,
zum Beispiel drei Monate lang diese Kiste oder fast diese Kiste buchen, also je nachdem
was ihr braucht, und bevor wir jetzt mit der eigentlichen Geschichte anfangen, warum sollte
man sich ne Linux Server hinstellen bzw. sollte man das überhaupt machen, das ist ja die
nächste Frage, ist das überhaupt sinnvoll, und da spoilere ich an der Stelle schon mal,
wenn man nicht wirklich ne Kiste im Internet braucht, dann ist das sicherste immer noch
ne Kiste zu haben, die nicht im Internet ist, also wenn man einfach nur bei sich was laufen
lassen will, ist es total bescheuert, sich irgendwelche im Internet erreichbaren Kisten
hinzustellen, aber es kann natürlich auch seine Vorteile haben, je nachdem was man machen
will, zum Beispiel der Klassiker dürfte wahrscheinlich irgendein Minecraft Server sein, und wenn
ich den Minecraft Server baue für mich und meine Kollegen, dann würde ich den tatsächlich
irgendwo online hosten und nicht bei mir lokal, man kann den zwar lokal hosten, man kann sich
irgendein Raspberry Pi hinstellen, eine VM machen oder sonst was, aber ich hätte gar
keinen Bock mich mit irgendwelchen Portweiterleitungen oder meinem Upload Speed auseinanderzusetzen
daheim, da würde ich mir lieber sowas kaufen, und es gibt natürlich, wie kommst du da drauf,
ich weiß ich höre mich so ähnlich an, du kannst dir einen Minecraft Server direkt kaufen
bei irgendeinem Anbieter, hat dann den Vorteil, du hast dann irgendein Management Interface,
wo du dann sich Mods anklicken kannst und sonst was, aber wenn du das wirklich selber
machen willst, dann ist das eigentlich das beste was du hier machen kannst, hier sowas
zu mieten.
Ich weiß nicht, wie hungrig das aktuelle Minecraft ist mit ein paar Plugins, aber ich
denke mal, mit einer Triple Core, mit einem Triple, auch RAM könnte bei Java ein bisschen
schwierig werden, kommt man auf jeden Fall ganz hin, und ihr könnt diesen Server mit
meinem Startguthaben quasi schon drei Monate verwenden, das ist jetzt neu mit AMD, nee
das war schon immer mit AMD, fast drei Monate verwenden und euch das Ganze mal angucken,
aber denkt dran, wenn das nicht ins Internet muss, dann ist es am besten, man stellt das
ganze Zeug erst mal gar nicht ins Internet, aber 4G RAM, wenn nicht viel drauf los ist,
da irgendwie 60 Spieler oder so sind, dann kommt man wahrscheinlich mit 4G RAM auch hin,
ich dachte auch, dass das neu ist mit AMD, da müsste ich die echt mal fragen, war das,
wann, ach nee genau, guck mal das ist jetzt ne Mischung, ah das ist neu, naja, und wenn
man sich dann überlegt hat, ok man braucht ne Linux Server, bzw. man möchte irgendwas
anbieten, was aus dem Internet erreichbar sein soll, das ist ja wie gesagt das erste
was man sich erstmal überlegen muss, wozu die das erwähnen, das ist ne gute Frage,
keine Ahnung, letztendlich macht es gar keinen Unterschied, also unten drunter, ob das jetzt
ne VM ist auf AMD Basis oder ne VM auf Intel Basis, ist doch vollkommen wurscht, normalerweise,
ich weiß jetzt nicht warum man das erwähnt, vielleicht, ich glaube sogar so Sachen wie
Krypto Extension, sowas haben die beide mittlerweile, ich weiß es nicht, keine Ahnung, das kann
nur sein, also wenn mich das interessieren würde, dann wirklich nur wenn ich ganz spezielle
Sachen verwenden will, die vielleicht nur Intel CPU, aber da fällt mir jetzt nicht
so viel ein, keine Ahnung, ich weiß nicht warum sie es erwähnen, aber ich könnte mir
vorstellen, sie erwähnen es aus dem Grund, falls dann jemand doch was machen will, was
sich funktioniert, dass er es vorher sieht, schadet ja nichts, also es schadet auf jeden
Fall nichts, wenn es da steht, warum sie es jetzt genau hinschreiben, ehrlich gesagt
keine Ahnung, bei den meisten Hausdinganbietern erfährst du es gar nicht, naja, mit was fange
ich jetzt am besten an, also wenn man sich überlegt hat, also wenn man sich überlegt
hat, man hat irgendein Anwendungsgebiet, ich mache mal eine Linux Kiste auf, man hat irgendein
Anwendungsgebiet wofür man einen Linux Server braucht, wie gesagt, die sichersten Server
sind die, die gar nicht im Internet sind, wenn man sich überlegt hat, man braucht das,
zum Beispiel weil man einen Minecraft Server für sich und seine Kollegen haben will, das
würde ich auf jeden Fall lieber auf sowas hier hosten, als auf einer eigenen Kiste daheim
mit Portweiterleitung oder zum Beispiel, wenn man eine öffentliche Webseite anbieten will,
da muss man sich aber auch überlegen, will man sich wirklich da selbst darum kümmern,
weil einen Server aufsetzen und da irgendwie so einen WordPress Mist oder sowas installieren
und nie wieder fliegen ist, fuck, was willst du von mir, achso, ja, ich habe geupdatet,
FroggerZ am Start, also ne, einfach nur eine Kiste installieren und der WordPress drauf
hauen ist Payneschamp, das will man nicht machen und nie wieder updaten, kann man alles
machen, aber da würde ich mich eher ein bisschen mehr mit dem Thema vorher beschäftigen, aber
Minecraft ist zum Beispiel was, wo ich weiß, dass das ganz viele machen wollen und wenn
ich wirklich nur eine Webseite haben will, da kann man sich vielleicht auch irgendein,
ja, irgendein anderes Hosting holen, allerdings es gibt ja mittlerweile viele Static Site Generator
Geschichten, sowas wie Hugo und sowas, das funktioniert folgendermaßen, da fallen dann
am Ende, also man macht seine Webseite, ich nenne es mal, kompiliert das am Ende, kommt
da eine statische HTML Webseite raus und die kann man dann relativ sicher überall drauf
laufen lassen, weil solange da nichts dynamisch ist, hat man auch keine Sicherheitsprobleme,
statische Webseiten sind somit das sicherste, was es gibt, was soll passieren, das was
Einfallstore bietet ist ja nicht der Webserver, also meistens nicht der Webserver, der irgendwelche
Webseiten ausliefert, sondern irgendwelchen Backend Kram, der nicht richtig funktioniert,
also sei es irgendein PHP im Backend oder sei es, meinetwegen, weil es im Chat gerade
irgendein Node.js was Probleme hat, irgendein ASP.NET was nicht richtig authentifiziert
hat oder sonstige Geschichten, das ist ja meistens das, was Probleme hat, einfach statische
Webseiten ausliefern ist eigentlich total problemlos.
Node.js kann man da drauf auch laufen, du kannst da drauf alles laufen lassen, es ist
ja ein vollständiger Linux Server, was auch noch beliebt ist, was ich mal ursprünglich
verwendet habe, ich glaube, das war sogar der Grund, warum ich mich damals bei Hetzner
angemeldet habe, deswegen heißt mein Account oder nee, nee, Schwachsinn, ich kann es euch
jetzt nicht zeigen, die Straße, in der ich wohne bei Hetzner heißt Unity Media Sackt,
Unity Media Sackt 25 oder irgendwie sowas, weil ich mich damals angemeldet habe, um
einen Tunnel aufzubauen für über IPv6 VPN, das ist nämlich auch was, wenn ihr beispielsweise
Vodafone habt und nur Dual Stack Lite und ihr wollt euch per VPN nach Hause verbinden
und ihr seid in einer blöden Lage, mal gucken, ob es da ein schönes Bild zugibt, und ihr
seid in einer blöden Lage, achso, das ist nicht den DS Lite, den ich jetzt gemeint
habe, das hier meine ich, und ihr habt beispielsweise, ihr wollt euch per VPN verbinden von unterwegs,
wo es nur IPv4 gibt bei manchen Anbietern, die meisten haben ja mittlerweile IPv6 oder
von der Arbeit oder sonst wo, egal, wenn ihr nur noch, wenn ihr nur IPv4 an einer Ecke
habt und Dual Stack Lite, was im Endeffekt ja über IPv6 geht bzw. der IPv4 Teil getunnelt
wird über IPv6 und dann beim Provider rausgeht, also im Prinzip, das ist eigentlich ein ganz
gutes Bild, was Vodafone macht bei Dual Stack Lite, dann braucht man irgendeinen Endpunkt
im Internet, der das Tunnel für einen übernimmt und dafür hatte ich mich, glaube ich, ursprünglich
mal sogar bei Hetzner angemeldet. Alter, ist das Max FPS? Ich weiß, ich höre mich
ähnlich an, ich höre mich ähnlich an, ja. Hates Champions, ich weiß, ja natürlich bin
ich, guck mal, der Avatar, die E-Modes, ist der Cousin, genau, war das letzte Preis, mein
Cousin, mein Cousin ist dumm, der versteht das eh nicht. Oder wie ging das? Cousin, genau,
der Cousin, Cousin. Zumindest, also, was Vodafone macht, ich glaube, das Bild hier ist, das
Bild hier ist best, genau, das ist tatsächlich ein gutes Bild für Dual Stack Lite, das erklärt
es. So, das erklärt nämlich auch, warum ihr keine Ports weiterleiten könnt, wenn ihr
Vodafone habt mit Dual Stack Lite. Was nämlich passiert, wobei nah so schön ist das Bild
dann doch nicht, das andere war technisch doch ein bisschen besser. Also, wenn ihr Vodafone
mit Dual Stack Lite habt, dann habt ihr hier euren Router von Unity Media, ihr habt eure
Windows-Kiste, die Windows-Kiste kriegt vom Router IPv4, IPv6, machen die sich irgendwie
untereinander aus, alles gut. So, und jetzt kommt der Witz an IP, an Dual Stack Lite,
ihr bekommt nur eine IPv6-Adresse und alles IPv4 wird getunnelt über dieses IPv6 und
ihr teilt euch dann beim Anbieter auf Ausgangsseite eine IPv4-Adresse mit vielen anderen Unity
Media oder Vodafone-Kundinnen. Das heißt, Port-Weiterleitung können in diesem Szenario
nicht funktionieren. Das ist unmöglich, es sei denn Unity Media gibt euch Zugriff auf
ihren Router und das werden sie nicht machen. Funktioniert nicht. So, und deswegen braucht
man einen Endpunkt im Internet, um das selbst zu tunneln und da kann man sich zum Beispiel
hier so einen billigen 3€, heute sind es nur noch 2,96€ Cloud-Kiste holen, eine CPU
2 GB RAM reicht dicker aus und dann kann man das durchtunneln mit dieser Kiste, mit IPv4
als Endpunkt. Das ist zum Beispiel auch was schönes, das ist der Grund, warum ich mich
damals ursprünglich bei Azenan angemeldet habe, um sowas zu machen. Ist natürlich nicht
der Standardfall, warum man einen Linux-Server irgendwie betreibt. Also das erste ist, was
man sich immer Gedanken machen muss, muss die Kiste wirklich ins Internet. Das wird
vielleicht hetzner nicht gefallen, dass ich prinzipiell sage, hey Leute, kauft euch alle
unbedingt VMs dort, aber ich will euch ja kein, dass ihr irgendwie Sicherheitsprobleme
bekommt. Also alles, was nicht ins Internet muss und was nicht im Internet erreichbar
sein muss, nicht ins Internet packen. Und das ist übrigens auch so ein genereller Ratschlag,
wenn ihr Sachen erst gar nicht uploadet irgendwo hin, dann habt ihr auch später keine Probleme,
wenn der Anbieter mal wieder nicht richtig auf seine Zugangsdaten aufpassen kann. Das
ist eigentlich das beste, was man machen kann. Also wenn man wichtige Sachen hat, wo man
auf gar keinen Fall will, dass die irgendjemand sieht, dann den Scheiß einfach nicht in die
Cloud laden. Also mit den Firewalls zeige ich gleich. So, und wenn man sich dann überlegt
hat, dass man sagt, ok, ich habe einen Anwendungszweck, zum Beispiel einen Minecraft-Server, was
ist denn so, was ist Minecraft technisch gerade, was verwendet man denn für einen Server?
Früher war das Bucket, hat man früher oder irgendwie so hieß das, glaube ich, Bucket
oder so. Nein, was verwendet man dann? Nicht Nitrado, das meine ich nicht. Paper. Ja. High
Performance, Spee-God-Fork. Mein Gott, also die Minecraft-Server-Landschaft ist auch schon
ganz schön schnelllebig. Ich hatte damals auch einen eingerichtet und das war Bucket
oder irgendwie so hieß das. Gab es sowas mal? Ah, Spee-God war Fork von Bucket, also das
heißt, das hier ist quasi der Fork in zweiter Generation von Bucket. Sehe ich das richtig?
Das ist bestimmt, es muss Java sein. Jaja, Cradle, wenn ich das schon sehe, muss Java
sein. Siehst ihr mal Leute, ich bin zu dumm in einem Java-Software-Projekt überhaupt
zu finden, wo der Source-Code ist. Wo ist denn der Source-Code? Work? Nee. Normalerweise
gibt es ja dann Source-Ordner, aber den gibt es hier nicht. Wo ist der Source-Code? Patches?
Ups, Server? Nee. Oh, das ist ja mal Big Brain, Alter, Git Patches-Dings. Build Data?
Nee. Man weiß es nicht. Man weiß es nicht, wo der Source-Code ist. Das ist natürlich
ein blödes Projekt. Paper? Das da? Ah, hier, Source. Ach du große Kacke. Ok, es ist Java-Gedöns,
das gucken wir uns jetzt nicht näher an. Vorbei. Oh, sogar so ein Git-Commit ist Big Brain
bei denen. Zumindest, also, ich will ja gar keinen Minecraft-Server jetzt irgendwie,
ist mir eigentlich egal, ihr könnt Minecraft-Server verwenden, was ihr lustig seid. Ihr könnt
auch den offiziellen verwenden, keine Ahnung, wie der ist. Aber wenn ihr den Anwendungszwerg
habt und sagt, hey, das will ich laufen lassen, zum Beispiel ein Minecraft-Server für irgendwelche
Freunde oder es gibt bestimmt noch irgendwelche Oldschool-Leute, die den Half-Life-Deathmatch-Server
oder sowas laufen lassen wollen oder einen CS-Server oder was auch immer, ja, man hat
die Möglichkeit, das lokal zu machen mit irgendwelchen Portweiterleitungen, sofern man nicht hinter
dir als Light ist. Würde ich aber nicht machen, du musst Ports weiterleiten auf irgendeinen
Server bei dir intern, das wäre mir nichts, dann würde ich mir wirklich einen Server mieten.
Sprich, wenn ihr den Anwendungszwerg habt, dann ist das nächste, was ihr euch fragen
müsst in Windows oder Linux und die Antwort ist relativ einfach, Linux. Und dann, wenn
ihr euch dafür entschieden habt, ist die nächste Frage, welche Distribution nimmt man denn
für Server? Was gibt's denn da so? Und die ganze Zeit war das so, es gibt, es gab drei,
es gab drei Stück. Es gibt Debian, obwohl, es gibt eigentlich immer noch drei Stück,
aber, nein, nicht Arch und auch nicht Gentoo, garantiert, garantiert kein Gentoo auf dem
Server. Man muss nämlich unterscheiden zwischen, will man einen Desktop-OS oder will man einen
Server-OS. Und ganz im Ernst, als Server-OS, Gentoo und Arch ist jetzt vielleicht nicht
so die intuitivste Wahl, ja. So, also das sind eigentlich die drei großen, die es gibt.
Es gibt Debian, das ist so das Älteste, schlechthin, weil ich mir gar nicht sicher bin, ob, Red hat
nicht vielleicht ähnlich alt ist, keine Ahnung. Aber Debian ist alt. Also die drei
Dinger gibt's im Prinzip. Ich weiß, es gibt noch mehr, aber das sind so die verbreitetsten.
Du hast Debian, du hast Ubuntu Server, Ubuntu ist ein Debian mit noch ein paar Dinger dabei.
Gucken wir gleich. So, und da hast du Red Hat. Das Problem an Red Hat ist, es kostet was.
Zumindest das offizielle Enterprise Linux von Red Hat, das kostet was. Und das ist gar
nicht mal so billig. Wir gucken uns mal. OnKS. Gucken wir uns mal an, ich weiß gar nicht,
wo sieht man da das Pricing mittlerweile. Die Red Hat Seite ist auch echt Cancer. Da findest
du gar nichts. Die Red Hat Seite ist wirklich grausam. Products, meine Güte. Darf ich das
jetzt öffnen? Red Hat Enterprise Linux. Der Vorteil von Red Hat ist natürlich, wenn man
das gekauft hat und je nach Paket kriegt man dafür auch Support. Der Support ist aber zumindest
das, was ich bisher mit dem Red Hat Support hatte. Das war eher so die typische Enterprise
Support Geschichte. So nach dem Motto, wir machen ein Ticket auf, der Typ, der das Ticket
bearbeitet, schreibt nochmal das gleiche rein in eigenen Worten und fragt, ob man das
Ticket wieder schließen kann. Store. Store. Was einfach Store. Ich leg da nicht mehr durch
auf der Seite von denen. Also da seht ihr, das ist gar nicht so billig. Das ist schon
ordentlich. Dafür bekommt man, aber das ist für den Heimgebrauch komplett unsinnig.
Ich zeig das jetzt nochmal, so der Vollständigkeit halber. Das bringt es nicht. JBoss ist ein
Java Application Server. Das bringt es nicht. Das ist vielleicht was im Enterprise umfällt,
wenn man sagt, wir haben jetzt hier ein paar Kisten und möchten sichergehen, dass im Zweifelsfall
auch die nächsten 8 Jahre über, wenn wir spezifische Probleme haben, die sonst keiner
hat, jemand für uns Patches macht, was auch immer. Dann reicht übrigens das kleinste
Paket noch gar nicht. Das kleinste Paket, wo ist denn hier, da gibt es ja sogar noch
Support-Paket-Unterschiede. Das kleinste Paket kannst du glaube ich noch nicht mal
direkt ein Ticket aufmachen oder sowas. Das lohnt sich eigentlich fast gar nicht, das
kleinste Paket zu kaufen. Ich blicke da nicht durch. Es ist egal, Red Hat verwenden wir
eh nicht. Das Schöne an Red Hat war, es gab die ganze Zeit einen Red Hat Nachbau. Man
muss sagen, im Enterprise Umfeld, also hier Business Stonks, ist Red Hat sehr beliebt.
Das liegt daran, weil für Red Hat viele Sachen zertifiziert sind. Zum Beispiel war Oracle
Datenbank Sachen lange Zeit zertifiziert für Red Hat. Mittlerweile hat Oracle was
Eigenes. Die haben nämlich Oracle Enterprise Linux. Wüsst ihr euch nicht alles merken,
ich zeige es nur der Vollständigkeit halber, dass es das gibt. Lasst einfach die Finger
von, das ist was, das könnt ihr im Business Umfeld machen, für privat ist das vollkommen
egal. Dann gibt es auch noch, sollte man auch noch erwähnen, es gibt noch SUSE. Wie heißt
denn das SUSE Server Ding? SUSE Linux Enterprise Server gibt es auch noch. Kam mal ursprünglich
aus Deutschland. Ich weiß gar nicht wo die jetzt sind. Meinung zu SUSE, ich finde es
ein kleines Champ. Was macht denn das Windows hier für komische Geräusche im Hintergrund?
Kann es mal die Klappe halten. Typische Windows Aktion. Wir haben es 5 Minuten später angeschaltet,
Restart Now. Wem gehört denn SUSE eigentlich? Im Zweifelfall gehört es irgendwelchen China-Chinesen
oder so. So SUSE, wem gehört denn das jetzt? Microf Pocos. Okay, die sind anscheinend noch
in Nürnberg. Na gut. So, sollte man auch mal gesehen haben, dass es das gibt, ist aber
jetzt, ich muss ehrlich sagen, ich habe es noch nie erlebt, dass es verwendet wird.
Die einzige, den einzigen Fall, also großflächig den einzigen Fall, den ich gesehen habe,
war für eine Telefonanlage, wo die Software nur für SUSE zertifiziert war. Was ist die
beste Dealungs-Server-Distribution? Komme ich gleich zu, ich bin auch Ubuntu-Fan, was
das angeht. SUSE brauchst du, wenn du SAP-Support haben willst. Okay, dann weiß ich schon mal,
warum ich kein SUSE verwende. Ich will nämlich, also nicht, dass noch einer auf die Idee kommt,
man müsste was mit SAP machen. Also dann ist am besten kein SUSE verwenden, dann kann man
auch kein SAP haben und dann sind alle glücklich. So, also das gibt es auch noch. SUSE. Aber
die meistverbreitetsten kann man sagen, denke ich mal, kann man sagen, es ist Debian, Ubuntu
und Red Hat. Und das Schöne an Red Hat ist, die ganze Zeit gab es dort CentOS, das war
ein Nachbau von Red Hat. Also, da muss ich jetzt mal kurz ausholen, so fünf Minuten lang,
warum geht das überhaupt? Also wir haben es ja gesehen, Red Hat verkauft ihren Kram. Warum
gibt es davon einen kostenlosen Nachbau? Naja, was alle Linux-Distributionen machen,
ist ja im Endeffekt nur, in Anführungsstrichen nur, da gehört einiges dazu, nur Software
nehmen und die packagen und anbieten. Also sie nehmen quasi alles, was es so an freier
Software gibt, was sie sinnvoll halten, packen das zusammen und veröffentlichen Patches
für und bringen da halt quasi so eine Software-Zusammenstellung raus. Das ist ja eine Linux-Distribution
im Endeffekt. Das heißt, die Software, die Red Hat in seinem Linux mitliefert, ist eigentlich
Open-Source-Software. Das heißt, Red Hat kann da zwar für ihren Service-Geld verlangen
oder gut, du darfst ja Open-Source-Software verkaufen, haben wir letztens uns schon mal
kaputt gelacht, dass man beim Saturn VLC kaufen kann für 9,99 Euro. Markeeschi1, danke schon
für den Zap. Also es ist nicht verboten, Open-Source-Software zu verkaufen, aber was du machen musst
ist, zumindest bei den meisten Lizenzen, ist es so, dass wenn du eine Distribution baust
und Patches baust und so was, du musst deinen Source-Code wiederum veröffentlichen. Das
ist ja so einer der Grundgedanken von Linux, was übrigens auch viel Kritik gibt, dass
sobald du Software nimmst und die änderst, du deine Software wieder quasi Open-Source
machen musst. Ne, wir haben uns gerade die News dazu angeguckt zu der Microsoft-Distro.
So, und deswegen ging das mit CentOS, also sprich, Red Hat bietet die Distribution hier
von ihnen an, Red Hat Enterprise Linux, du musst auch deine Gebühren dafür bezahlen,
dass du Zugriff zu den Patches und alles bekommst. Aber was CentOS jetzt gemacht hat, ist folgendes,
nachdem Red Hat ja dazu verpflichtet war oder verpflichtet ist, ihren Source-Code offenzulegen,
kam dann CentOS her und hat quasi alle Red Hat Bestandteile, die nicht frei waren, wie
zum Beispiel das Red Hat Logo, haben die ausgetauscht und haben im Endeffekt Red Hat Linux genommen,
haben alles rausgepatcht, was Red Hat ist und haben daraus CentOS gebaut. So und CentOS
war eigentlich jahrelang das, was man oftmals so im Bankumfeld, wo ich arbeite, was man
da gesehen hat. Die Leute wollten eigentlich ein Red Hat haben, weil eben vieles für Red
Hat zertifiziert ist, aber im Endeffekt haben sie dann unterm Strich CentOS verwendet. Und
das ging jahrelang so. Es gab dann noch so einen kleinen Trick, davon darf man gar nicht
so laut erzählen, aber ich habe das von vielen jetzt schon gehört, also das passiert nicht
nur an einer Stelle. Es ist zum Beispiel so, dass man ja trotzdem im Endeffekt ein nachgebautes
Red Hat hatte mit CentOS. Das heißt, wenn was kaputt war, hat man vielleicht doch mal
ganz gerne den Red Hat Support in Anspruch genommen, was ja nicht ging, wenn man CentOS
hat. Also, und das haben wir auch gemacht, das haben wir auch gemacht, also ich weiß,
das ist aus erster Hand. Man hatte dann 3-4 fette Red Hat Systeme bezahlt mit der größten
Lizenz und immer, wenn irgendein System Probleme hatte, also ein CentOS System unter anderem
Probleme hatte, dann hat man versucht, dieses Problem auf den fetten Red Hat Kisten nachzustellen
und ist dann zu Red Hat gegangen und hat gesagt, hey Red Hat, wir haben ein Problem, könnt
ihr das nicht mal irgendwie fixen? Also sprich, die 4 Kisten, die Red Hat installiert hat mit
offizieller Lizenz, die hatten gefühlt irgendwie 100.000 Probleme, in Wirklichkeit waren das
für alle 5.000 anderen Server. Gut, ich weiß, dass es viele andere auch so gemacht haben,
das ist nichts Neues, aber die Preise von Red Hat sind auch echt gesalzen. Das Einzige,
was das noch toppt ist Oracle Enterprise Linux und da übrigens, jetzt wo wir schon bei ein
bisschen Serverdistributionen Geschichte schon sind, übrigens, Red Hat Enterprise Linux
war ursprünglich auch, steht ja auch hier, war ursprünglich auch ein Red Hat Nachbau
und wisst ihr, wie Oracle das damals versucht hat durchzudrücken, dass man Oracle Linux
verwenden sollte? Die haben gesagt, ja, nur mit Oracle Linux spart ihr bei den Lizenzgebühren.
Es ist was, wo ich mich bis heute frage, ob das rechtlich eigentlich in Ordnung war.
Also, wenn du zum Beispiel eine Oracle Datenbank installieren wolltest, auf einem ESX, dann
haben die gesagt, also auf VM, eine VM mit Oracle installieren wolltest, dann hat Oracle
damals gesagt, ich weiß nicht, wie es heute ist, aber ich vermute mal immer noch so, hat
Oracle gesagt, nein, du kannst das nicht einfach so installieren, du brauchst eine Lizenz für
die CPU Kerne auf dem Host, also sprich, du hast eine VM installiert, mit sagen wir 4
CPU Kern, dann wollte Oracle nicht etwa lizenziert werden für 4 CPU Kerne, sondern für 32 CPU
Kerne, die der Host hatte, die die VM aber überhaupt nicht gesehen hat. Das war damals
Lizenzpolitik von Oracle, wahrscheinlich ist das heute immer noch so. So, und dann kam
Oracle um die Ecke und hat gesagt, aber, aber, aber, Moment, Moment, Moment, wenn ihr Oracle
Enterprise Linux verwendet, dann ist das nicht so, dann könnt ihr das alles machen. Und
nachdem Oracle Enterprise Linux ja ein Red Hat Nachbau war, haben viele gesagt, okay,
wir verwenden für unser Oracle Zeug einfach Oracle Enterprise Linux. Ich frage mich bis
heute, ob das nicht irgendwie Ausnutzung ihrer Stellung war, keine Ahnung, aber anscheinend
ist das okay gewesen. Ja, so, gibt es auch noch, verwendet kein Mensch, nur um, die einzigen
ist, um Oracle Lizenzgebühren zu sparen. Ich weiß, Oracle hat jetzt eine eigene VM-Geschichte,
ich habe vergessen, wie es heißt, das habe ich auch schon mal das Web-Interface vorhin
gesehen, war ganz, ganz grausam. Es ist wurscht. So, ähm, nächstes ist CentOS war ein Nachbau
von Red Hat, das gibt es jetzt nicht mehr und das ist das größte Problem. CentOS hat
gesagt, CentOS wird es ab Red Hat Enterprise Linux 8 in der Version nicht mehr geben, was
natürlich scheiße ist. Wir haben, by the way, auf der Arbeit auch über 5000 Kisten CentOS,
das wird noch lustig, siebener, siebener aber. Und das gibt es nicht mehr, das ist natürlich
ein Problem. Das hat ganz viele, gerade die CentOS verwenden, ganz viele dazu gebracht
jetzt zu sagen, hm, ob das noch die Zukunft ist, ich weiß es nicht. Und es gibt jetzt
einen Nachbau, es gibt einen neuen CentOS Versuch, das ist Rocky Linux, aber Rocky Linux ist noch
nicht so etabliert, wie das CentOS war. Ich muss euch ehrlich sagen, ich habe auch in
the wild noch keine, keine Rocky Linux Installation gesehen, die versuchen das gleiche zu machen,
wie CentOS quasi Red Hat nachzubauen. Warum gibt es das nicht mehr? Weil das Projekt
eh schon zum größten Teil Red Hat gehört hat und Red Hat gesagt hat, sie wollen das
nicht mehr haben. Pesch. So, und bei uns ist es jetzt folgendermaßen gelaufen, wir
haben ganz viel CentOS, aber wir ziehen ja auch relativ viel in die Cloud um und was
wir auf der Arbeit jetzt sagen ist, wir verwenden für alles neue Ubuntu. Fertig. Guckt Red
Hat auch in die Röhre. So, und da sind wir schon, ich lese übrigens gleich den Chat
und beantworte die Sachen, die noch drin stehen. Dann kommen wir jetzt mal nämlich
zu den zwei wichtigen Sachen, auch für den Heimbereich, das war so hier Business Enterprise
Stonks Exkurs, was Linux angeht. Langsamer für den Sub, Stripes107, der hat dem Renux
eingegiftet, exzellent, der hat es verdient, ja. So, und da kommen wir nämlich zu zwei
Betriebssystemen Linux Server technisch, die für den Heimbereich eigentlich mit am interessantesten
sind. CentOS war auch interessant, solang es das gegeben hat, aktuell war, aber das hat
sich ja erledigt. Rocky Linux wird vielleicht noch interessant. Es gibt Debian, Debian ist
eigentlich so das Oldschool Linux schlechthin. Guck mal, das geht los von 1993. Also Debian
ist so das Oldschool Ding schlechthin. So, das ist immer noch sehr beliebt und gehört
eben mit Debian, Ubuntu und CentOS zu den großen drei Distributionen, die serverseitig
verwendet werden. 1993 war der Max noch jung, ja das stimmt, ich bin 1984 geboren, da war
ich neun. Da war ich aber noch nicht Zoomer, weil Zoomer gab es damals noch nicht als Bezeichnung.
Da war ich Boomer, ohne zu wissen, dass ich mal Boomer werde. Wie nennt man das dann?
Pre-Boomer. Was für ein Linux Distro? Das ist Manjaro mit E3WM. So, also Debian ist
alt. Debian ist aber gleichzeitig eines der stabilsten Distributionen, die es gibt und
deswegen ist das auch serverseitig so beliebt. Es gibt auch Leute, die betreiben den Desktop
auf Debian. Also man muss sagen, Debian ist keine Distribution, die sagen wir sind eine
Server Distribution in dem Sinn. Doch, sagen sie schon, aber eigentlich sagen sie wir sind
Debian Linux, ihr könnt uns für alles verwenden. Also du kannst es für Desktop verwenden,
für was auch immer. Debian ist Debian. Das Problem bei Debian ist, dadurch, dass das
so stabil ist, also die erkaufen sich die Stabilität ein bisschen dadurch, dass ihre
Software alt ist. Also sprich, wenn eine Debian Distribution, was ist die aktuelle Buster,
ist Buster das aktuelle Debian? Haben wir da irgendwie eine History? Ja, Buster, Buster
ist aktuell. Guck mal, Buster kam raus 2019 und das ist das Problem von Debian. Debian
ist, also was heißt das Problem? Das ist ein Nachteil von Debian, das kann aber auch gleichzeitig
ein Vorteil sein. Also das ganze kam vor zwei Jahren 2019 raus und die Software, die dabei
war, die war damals schon nicht die neueste. Also ihr könnt euch vorstellen, Debian-Pakete
sind in die Jahre gekommen. Gerade wenn die Distribution schon ein paar Jahre auf Pucke
hat, bis das nächste Stable rauskommt. Und ihr seht es ja hier, zwischen so zwei Debian-Releases
liegen so zwei Jahre. Das heißt, wenn die Software schon nicht die neueste ist, wenn
das rauskommt, ist es zwei Jahre später eh komplett, komplett hinüber. Aber es geht,
es geht. Der große Vorteil davon ist halt, der Kram ist stabil. Also wenn du was Stabiles
haben willst, dann kannst du mit Debian nicht viel verkehrt machen. Raspberry Pi ist mit
Debian quasi groß geworden. Das bietet sich natürlich für Server an, weil bei Servern
ist es erstmal wurscht, ob du den neuesten GNOME Desktop oder sonst was bekommst. Wichtig
ist eher, dass dein Kram funktioniert und stabil ist. Deswegen ist Debian im Server-Umfeld
so beliebt und ein Vorteil, was Debian noch hat ist, Debian kann man ziemlich minimalistisch
installieren. Also Debian hat einen Net-Installer oder einen Minimal-Installer, der hat, glaube
ich, ich weiß nicht, vielleicht hat es einer von euch mal ausprobiert, irgendwie 150 MB
nach der Installation. Also du kriegst quasi ein komplett lauffälliges Betriebssystem
mit 150 MB. Das ist nicht groß, so ein Standard, so ein Minimal-Debian. Das ist wirklich ziemlich,
ziemlich klein. Ja klar, wenn du dann Sachen nachinstallierst, dann hast du trotzdem wieder
viel drauf, aber standardmäßig hast du erstmal wirklich ziemlich minimalistisch. Hier neben
sieht man auch die Package-Auswahl. Es gibt, vermute man, dass es die Packages sind. Genau,
also Debian bringt mittlerweile 57.000 Pakete mit, also Pakete, quasi Software. Was ziemlich
groß ist, ich würde aber sagen, dass sich das gar nicht so viel nimmt. Also die wichtigsten
Sachen gibt es unter allen größeren Distributionen. Die Distribution mit der größten Pakete,
die Pakete-Auswahl, wenn wir jetzt mal alle Linux-Distributionen nehmen, würde ich sagen,
ist tatsächlich Arch Linux oder eventuell Gentoo, wenn man Kram selbst kompilieren will. Aber
Arch mit User-Repos dürfte an Software-Auswahl kaum zu überbieten sein. Da hast du ja wirklich
jeden noch so größten abgedrehten Schwachsinn drinne. Mit dem Unterschied, das interessiert
dich auf dem Server halt nicht. Deswegen ist Debian Server-Technik sehr beliebt. Du hast,
du hast alles Wichtige dabei. Du hast es auch meistens relativ gut vorkonfiguriert, dass
wenn du es installierst, halt ordentlich Basis-Basic-Config hat und es ist stabil. Deswegen ist
Debian beliebt. Nachteil von Debian ist, die Software ist alt. So, und dann kam ein bisschen
danach, man Debian ist von 1993, irgendwann so, ich sag jetzt einfach mal 10 Jahre später,
ich bin mir nicht ganz sicher. 10 Jahre später kam dann irgendwann mal Ubuntu aus Top Südafrika
oder wie die Amis sagen, Juubantu. Wie Fanzulu, genau. Ich glaube aus Südafrika kommen die.
Guck mal, war schon 10 Jahre später gar nicht so weit nebendran. So, also ungefähr 10 Jahre
später kam dann Ubuntu und die haben folgendes gemacht. Die nehmen Debian als Grundlage,
also sie verwenden die gleichen Packages wie Debian, also das gleiche Package-Format wie
Debian nur, die haben ein paar Sonderlocken, nur das Ubuntu sagt, wir machen jedes halbe
Jahr eine neue Distribution und für Leute, denen Stabilität wichtig ist, machen wir
einen Long-Term Support Release. Das heißt, mal gucken, ob es da was besseres gibt als
diese Tabelle hier oben. Ubuntu hat auch so seine Eigenheiten, genau. Hier sieht man die
Ubuntu Releases ganz gut. Also ihr seht, es kommt jedes halbe Jahr ein neues Ubuntu raus,
aber alle zwei Jahre, so ungefähr wie Debian, alle zwei Jahre gibt es einen LTS Release,
das dann aber auch richtig lange, nämlich guckt euch mal hier an, 5 Jahre ist das glaube
ich ne. Haben die das jetzt nicht verkürzt seit 2004? Ne, aber guckt mal, es ist 5 Jahre
aktuell. Also das ist im Prinzip so das Beste aus beiden Welten, wenn man das so will. Deswegen
habe ich ursprünglich auch mal gesagt, ok ich verwende nur noch Ubuntu auf meinen Kisten,
also nicht auf der Arbeit, sondern für alle anderen, weil ich irgendwie mal auf den Geschmack
gekommen bin, habe ich gesagt, ok Ubuntu LTS ist eigentlich eine super Geschichte, du
kriegst 5 Jahre lang Patches, du kriegst 5 Jahre lang teilweise Software Aktualisierung,
also es ist nicht 5 Jahre lang uralt wie Debian, zumindest was kernel und sowas angeht, mit
Patches und allem möglichen, die haben ja als, wie hieß der Kram, Meltdown und Spectre
rausgekommen ist, da haben die teilweise noch 4 Jahre alt Linux Geschichten rückwirkend
gepatcht. Also das ist eigentlich ne richtig gute Geschichte. LTS ist Long Term Support,
also du siehst die normalen Ubuntu Versionen, die sind immer quasi aktuell ungefähr bis
zur nächsten Version und alle 2 Jahre gibt es eine LTS Version. Das könnte man so sehen,
entweder man braucht die neuere Software, dann nimmt man das da, z.B. auf dem Desktop
oder man nimmt das da, aber man kann genauso gut Debian verwenden, wenn man das will. Also
ich würde sagen, es nimmt sich eigentlich nicht viel. Du kannst Debian verwenden, genau,
Debian hat ja auch sowas, Debian schmeißt ja den Kram nicht weg, das sieht man ja hier
z.B. dran, Debian schmeißt den Kram ja auch nicht weg, also sprich, wenn das hier nicht
mehr aktuell ist, also bald kommt Dings hier Bullseye raus, nächsten Monat oder so, genau,
24. August, dann wird das hier All-Stable, so wie das jetzt Stretch ist, also sprich
guck, das geht dann bis 2024. Also die haben ungefähr das gleiche, also deswegen, worauf
ich hoffe, das nimmt sich nicht so viel. Es gibt Debian auch als Extended LTS, das habe
ich noch nie verwendet, aber das haben die hier auch, du kannst denen hier auch Geld geben,
aber 5 Jahre ist finde ich schon eine super Geschichte, egal ob jetzt Debian oder Ubuntu,
also bei 5 Jahren kann ich mich jetzt eigentlich nicht beschweren, gerade im privaten Bereich
ist das auch erstmal wurscht. Zumindest, das ist so der hauptsächliche Unterschied, in
der Regel kannst du sagen, Debian ist halt sehr drauf ausgelegt, minimalistisch zu sein
und viele Pakete zu haben, aber halt stabile Software und nicht unbedingt die aktuellste
und Ubuntu sagt halt, ok, achso und eine Sache auch noch ein großer Unterschied ist, Debian
ist äußerst strikt, was das Mitliefern von Paketen angeht, also wenn Debian auch nur
den kleinsten Zweifel daran hat, dass die Rechte an der Software nicht geklärt sind
oder dass in irgendeiner Software irgendwelche Binary's mitgeliefert werden, die nicht open
source sind, ursprünglich oder was auch immer, dann lehnt Debian den Kram ab. Also Debian
legt sehr viel Wert darauf, dass die minimalistisch sind, große Software aus haben, aber quasi
open source um jeden Preis. Gibt Leute denen das gefällt, gibt da Leute sagen, ok, mir
wäre es lieber, man hat vielleicht noch ein bisschen mehr Auswahl, aber scheiß drauf,
ob das jetzt frei ist oder nicht und Ubuntu hat ein bisschen so die Taktik, sie liefern
eben auch Sachen mit, die vielleicht ein bisschen fragwürdig sind, zum Beispiel NVIDIA Treiber,
NVIDIA Treiber werdet ihr auf Debian so in der Form nicht sehen, bei Ubuntu ist das kein
Ding, bei Ubuntu musst du zwar auch sagen, ok, ich weiß was ich da mache, die fragen
dich nochmal, aber du kriegst zum Beispiel NVIDIA Treiber für deine Grafikkarte unter
Ubuntu, unter Debian kannst du das vergessen, du kannst das alles selbst machen, ja, aber
du kannst nicht drauf hoffen, wenn das da irgendwelche unfreie Binary Sachen drin sind,
dass Debian das mitliefert. Selbst AMD Treiber auf Debian, ich muss ehrlich sagen, ich habe
ewig keine Hardware-Linux-Geschichte mehr mit Debian ausprobiert. Zumindest vor, frag mich
was war das, 5-6 Jahren oder so, wo ich das zuletzt probiert habe im Notebook, da war das
unter Ubuntu easy as fuck, du hast das installiert, der hat sogar gesagt, hey Jungs, wir haben
eine NVIDIA Karte erkannt, willst du NVIDIA Grafikkarten Treiber installieren, alles gut.
Es kann sein, dass sich das mittlerweile gebessert hat, dass NVIDIA jetzt auch Dinger hat, die
vertiebel sind zu ihrer, zur Debian-Philosophie, keine Ahnung. Achso, ja, das gab es vorher
auch schon, genau, du kannst unfree, du kannst non-free anmachen in Debian, ja. Aber das ist
gut zu wissen, dass es jetzt einfacher ist. Zumindest hier sind so die grundsätzlichen
Unterschiede. Allerdings, man muss jetzt mal Ubuntu nicht so sehr loben, die haben auch
ein paar Sachen, wo ich mir denke, warum muss das sein, das gucken wir uns jetzt auch gleich
an. Zum Beispiel ist Ubuntu der Meinung, so ein eigentlicher Package-Manager alleine
reicht uns nicht, wir haben so ein eigenes Ding noch gebaut, weil wir sind cool und wir
sind canonical und wir sind die geilsten. So, die haben sich sowas ausgehört wie Snap,
als App-Store. Gibt es denn sowas hier? Das war mal gedacht, tja, gute Frage, als was
waren das eigentlich mal gedacht, Mocha-S. Es ist zwar so als App-Store oder so mal gedacht,
keine Ahnung, ich weiß bis heute nicht, was die sich dabei gedacht haben. Zumindest versuchen
die unter Ubuntu dir manchmal Snaps unterzuschieben. Also Snaps sind keine klassischen Debian-Pakete
mehr, so wie die meisten Sachen nur Debian unter Ubuntu, sondern Snaps sind quasi eigene
Images, die als Container laufen, die aber so ins System integriert werden, als wären
sie keine Container. Komisches Zeug, ich weiß ehrlich gesagt bis heute nicht, warum man
das braucht. Es ist auch nicht das einzige, du hast Snap, dann hast du App-Image-Geschichte,
dann hast du, wie heißt das andere Ding nochmal, was es gibt? Flatpak, Flatpak, genau, Flatpak
gibt es auch noch. Zumindest ich habe damit gar kein Problem, dass es diese Techniken
gibt, das ist ja alles schön und gut. Was ich dumm finde an Ubuntu ist, dass sie dir
das teilweise unterschieben. Wenn du nämlich unter Ubuntu Chrome installierst, dann installiert
er nicht einfach einen Package Chrome, sondern der installiert erst mal Snap und lädt sich
das aktuelle Chrome Snap runter, das finde ich total hängen geblieben. Das ist Paintchamp,
dass es den Kram gibt, habe ich keine Schmerzen mit, dass quasi aber über den normalen Up-Package-Manager
Sachen installiert werden, die keine Up-Packages sind, finde ich doof. Also das ist das, was
mir an Ubuntu auf den Keks geht und dann gibt es noch etwas, was mich unter Ubuntu nervt.
Wahrscheinlich werdet ihr euch denken können, das ist Netplan. Irgendjemand bei Ubuntu
oder bei Canonical ist auf die glorreiche Idee gekommen und hat gesagt, hey, wir haben
eine einfache Netzwerk-Config, wir haben eine einfache Netzwerk-Config in Textform, die
jeder versteht, wir machen jetzt eine einfache Netzwerk-Config in Textform, aber in Yammel,
warum auch immer. Ich habe mich mittlerweile auch dran gewünscht, aber ich weiß bis heute
nicht, warum man das braucht. Ich verstehe es nicht. So, so weit die Übersicht über
so die vergängigen Betriebssysteme Linux Server technisch. Und eine Sache habe ich
ganz am Anfang gesagt, aber jetzt sind mehr Leute da, sage ich das nochmal, nicht einfach
random irgendeinen Server ins Internet stellen, wenn es nicht sein muss. Am besten und sichersten
ist die Sache immer noch, wenn es erst gar nicht erreichbar ist. Was nicht läuft, kann
es nicht angreifen, was nicht erreichbar ist, kann es nichts machen. Wenn du aber einen
Anwendungszweck hast, wie beispielsweise Minecraft Server für euch und eure Freunde oder ihr
haben Vodafone, DualStack Lite, wollt euch irgendwie durchtunneln oder ihr habt irgendeine
öffentliche, statische Webseite, die ihr hosten wollt, dann könnt ihr das machen.
Zum Beispiel gibt es ja mehrere Hosting-Anbieter, aber zum Beispiel könnt ihr das Ganze machen
bei Hetzner Cloud. Hetzner Cloud ist finde ich ganz praktisch. Ich habe ja da einiges
drauf laufen, unter anderem den Preis-Champ. Der Preis-Champ läuft auch auf Hetzner Cloud.
Weißt du gerade im Chat, einer schreibt, netcup habe ich probiert, die wollten von
mir eine Personalausweis-Kopie und da hatte ich keinen Bock drauf. Der Preis-Champ läuft
auch auf Hetzner Cloud. Preislich sind die gar nicht schlecht. Preislich sind die gar
nicht schlecht, man wird immer was finden, was irgendwie billiger ist. Man wird immer
was finden, was irgendwie billiger ist, aber ich bin der Ansicht, Preis-Leistungstechnik
sind die super. Und dazu kommt, das Ganze ist stündliche Abrechnung, d.h. du bezahlst
auch nur das, was du wirklich bezahlst. Das ist auf dem Vormarsch, das haben viele andere
Cloud-Anbieter auch mittlerweile. Also wenn du beispielsweise mal guckst zu Digital Ocean
oder sowas, die haben das auch, minütliche oder stündliche Abrechnung. Also wenn du
jetzt sag mal, du brauchst eine fette Kiste um was zu berechnen, 32 Kerne, 128 GB RAM,
330 Euro. Bei anderen Hosting-Anbietern hast du dann die Sache, ok, du musst das monatlich,
z.B. bei 1&1 oder sowas. Du musst das monatlich abbrechen, das ist natürlich Paynes-Champ.
Niemand braucht diesen Kram in einem Monat lang. Normalerweise. Ich habe mal Open Street
Maps Reprocessed für Routing-Informationen und ich habe die Kiste halt 4 Stunden gebraucht.
Und dann hat sich das echt gelohnt. Ich habe dann am Ende irgendwie, was ich 2 Euro bezahlt,
anstatt 330 Euro und war fertig nach 4 Stunden. Das war einfach zu viel für meinen lokalen
Rechner. Dafür ist das äußerst praktisch. Also ich finde preisleistungsmäßig sind die
wirklich super. Deswegen, wenn ihr es auch mal ausprobieren wollt, Ausrufezeichen Hetzner
in den Chat. Einer Grund ist Sellout-Modus starten. Kriegt ihr 20 Euro Startguthaben
mit meinem Gutschein. So und jetzt fangen wir mal an. Man kann übrigens lange darüber
diskutieren, welchen Anbieter man da jetzt nimmt. Es hat alles seine Vor- und Nachteile.
Man muss gucken, was für Standorte hat das ganze. Also sprich braucht man beispielsweise
ein Rechenzentrum in Indien oder sowas. Dann braucht man halt einen, der ein Rechenzentrum
in Indien hat. Was ist einem wichtig? Es gibt die Unterschiede zwischen Anbietern, aber
ich kann halt sagen, ich verwende Hetzner selbst schon lange. Ich habe damit wenig Probleme
und preisleistungsmäßig sind die auch super. Hetzner will auch eine Internitätsprüfung
für den Gutschein. Keine Ahnung, ich habe meinen Gutscheinkode selbst nicht ausprobiert.
Wollen sie nicht? Keine Ahnung, ich habe meinen Gutscheinkode selbst nicht eingelöst
bis jetzt. Hast du keine Facecam? Ich habe höchstens Catcam. So und es geht schon bei
einer kleinen Kiste los von 3 Euro im Monat. Also sprich, was ist das? 0,005 Euro. Was
ist denn das? Ein halber Cent die Stunde. Sehe ich das richtig? Das ist ein halber Cent
die Stunde. Das ist auch immer. Es ist auf jeden Fall nicht teuer. Warum bin Snap eigentlich
von so vielen gehasst? Ich kann es dir gar nicht so hundertprozentig erklären. Warum
ich Snap nicht mag, ist, weil die dir über einen normalen Package Manager was unterschieben.
Irgendwie hat hier eine Cam außer du. Cringe. Alter, huge massive cringe. Also wenn das
jetzt schon cringe ist, dann ist alles cringe, oder? Wäre es nicht mehr cringe, wenn ich
eine Cam hätte und da irgendwelche komischen Dinger davor jetzt machen würde. Wie kann
was nicht vorhanden ist cringe sein? Cringe, Bruder, cringe, Alter. Weirdchamp. So, also
fangen wir mal an. Jetzt kommen wir mal zu der eigentlichen Technikgeschichte. Alles
ist cringe, ja. Richtig cringe. Warum ändern sich die Preise? Weil das dynamisch ist. Ich
glaube mal je nach Auslastung. Also am Anfang waren wir bei 2,96 Euro. Die Preise schwanken.
Das schwankt so immer um 3 Euro rum. Die Preise sind Agile. Genau. Du hast auf Italien,
echt? Wo habe ich? Ach guck mal, ich habe auf Italien. Eher mal schon noch auf Deutschland.
Null Italien, Alter. Warum? Jetzt mal 2,96. Aber die schwanken trotzdem manchmal. Das
ist normal, dass die manchmal schwanken. Hast du mal ein Haskell programmiert? Nein. So,
also fangen wir mal an. Ich gucke jetzt gleich nochmal in Chat, falls ich irgendwas übersehen
habe. Wo habe ich denn hier meine Server-Konsolen? Also sagen wir zum Beispiel, ihr wollt eine
Minecraft-Server hosten oder irgendwas. Wir machen jetzt ruhig die basic steps für Linux-Server
anlegen, Key generieren und das Ganze. Wir sind ja super modern, wenn man das Ganze unter
Windows 11. Weil Windows 11, oh ne. Ah, ho. Nochmal restart, habe ich doch schon. Wie oft
soll ich den Kram noch nachspielen? Ich habe das jetzt schon, glaube ich, zweimal restartet.
Warum nicht unter Linux? Naja, weil die meisten Leute das unter Windows verwenden. Wir machen
es normalerweise immer unter Linux, alles Mögliche. Aber die meisten Leute verwenden
Windows. Und wir machen das nicht mit PuTTY, das sage ich euch auch gleich. PuTTY ist Pain's
Champ in the S. Was hat das jetzt für Schmerzen, restart? Oh, okay. Vielleicht fahren wir doch
unter Linux an, bis das durch ist. PowerShell hat jetzt tatsächlich auch SSH, ne? So, lassen
wir überlegen. Wo fangen wir an? Also ich habe mich jetzt drüber ausgelassen, was es
für verschiedene Server-SS gibt. Das sieht man hier übrigens auch. Also man hat zur
Auswahl, wenn man Server anlegt, ist übrigens bei allen Anbietern ungefähr ähnlich. Das
sieht ein bisschen anders aus, aber so die grundsätzlichen Sachen sind, meistens kann
man meistens übertragen. Also Hetzner hat halt in Nuremberg, in Faltenstein oder in
Helsinki, ich nehme eins von den beiden meistens. So, und das ist im Prinzip das nächste, was
ich vorhin schon gesagt habe. Beliebte Betriebssystem Ubuntu Debian CentOS. CentOS hat sich ein
bisschen ins Aus befördert. Dann haben sie noch Fedora. Fedora ist quasi das Community
oder das Desktop Red Hat, wenn man es so will. Was gibt es bei Apps New? Wo? Was? Apps New?
Keine Ahnung. Ach hier, da kannst du irgendwelche vorgefertigten Dinger schon gleich drauf
haben. Also wenn ihr mal Sicherheitsprobleme haben wollt, dann macht ein WordPress Server
öffentlich im Internet mit allen Ports weitergeleitet. Easy. Ne, ne, das machen wir nicht. Wir machen
kein WordPress. Ich gehe mal davon aus, das habe ich noch nicht ausprobiert, das können
wir vielleicht, das können wir das nächste Mal vielleicht auch mal ausprobieren. Ich
gehe mal davon aus, dass das im Endeffekt ein Base Image sein wird, was auch immer sie
daneben. Ubuntu Debian, keine Ahnung. Und dass danach halt ein Installer-Script läuft
oder irgendein Ansible-Script oder was auch immer, was das quasi schon einrichtet, dass
das nicht selber machen muss. Warum sind die Chrome Symbole beide blau? Weil es ein Chromium
ist und kein Chrom. Ich habe auch nur normalen Chrom. Ich habe auch normalen Chrom. Windows,
was willst du von mir? Remind me. Alles klar, gut, vorgas. Hat's geschafft. Vier Stück,
ok, was willst du Windows? Warum ist mein Kalender auf Japanisch? Ah, Windows, was
ist hier los, Alter? Was macht es? Was macht's? Fünf Fenster Xbox Store, not signed in, Alter.
Ah, hör auf, hör auf Windows, geh weg. Es ist ja wirklich ätzend. Ich weiß schon,
Windows ist cringe, Leute. Nicht, dass ich keine Webcam habe. Wenn was cringe ist, dann
ist es das hier. So, also wir legen jetzt erstmal eine Kiste an. Im Prinzip bei jedem Anbieter
ähnlich. Bei Hetzner funktioniert folgendermaßen, ihr wählt erstmal die Location aus, dann
sucht ihr euch irgendein Betriebssystem raus. Wir nehmen jetzt Ubuntu 20.04. Warum 20.04?
Weil es das letzte LTS ist. Wer jetzt richtig big brain ist, Leute, wann ist das nächste
Ubuntu LTS? Wann kommt das nächste Ubuntu LTS? 22.04, korrekt. Ich gebe zu, war jetzt
nicht so kompliziert. 22.04. Die Sachen sind erstmal vollkommen wurscht. Einfach Standard
lassen. So, und das hier ist das, was es kostet. Man muss nämlich wissen, und das ist ein
bisschen trickreich bei Hetzner. Ich vermute ja mal, es ist Absicht, aber man muss es wissen.
Man könnte jetzt ja auf die Idee kommen, zum Beispiel zu sagen, okay, ich brauche diese
Kiste, weil ich will drei Kerne haben und vier Gigabyte RAM. Könnte man jetzt ja sagen.
Die Sache ist nur die, ich zeige euch das jetzt gleich mal, die Sache ist nur die, genau,
Elex Critical Information, die Sache ist die, was cool ist und was normalerweise total easy
funktioniert, wirklich Pluspunkte auch von der Hetzner Cloud sind. Du kannst das dynamisch
skalieren. Ich zeige euch das mal. Wir nehmen jetzt die kleinste Kiste. Wir nehmen jetzt
die kleinste Kiste. Ich mache mal ein SSH Key dran. Ne, machen wir nicht, wir machen
es ohne SSH Key. Ich zeige euch nämlich gleich, wie man das alles macht. So, Server, was
hat er hier für Schmerzen? No SSH Key selected, Root Passwort per Mail, alles klar. So, anlegen.
So, und jetzt gibt es ein paar Sachen, worauf man achten muss. Hostname, die sogar IP liegt,
ihr könnt den Server wieder dedoßen, wenn ihr wollt. Macht ihr mal. So, und jetzt kann
man Folgendes machen. Die Kiste hat jetzt ein CPU Kern und 20 Gigabyte, 20 Gigabyte Festplatte,
2 Gigabyte RAM und kostet 2,99 Euro im Monat. Jetzt könnte es ja sein und das ist eigentlich
ein super, ein super Feature. Jetzt könnte es ja sein, dass man sagt, hey, ich brauche
was größeres. Also sagen wir mal, ihr habt den Server eingerichtet. Wenn man jetzt noch
schreiben könnte, ihr habt den Server eingerichtet und sagt, ah, das reicht nicht, was ich habe
an. Bin ich jetzt blöd, das zu finden? Also wenn ihr sagt, mir reicht diese eine CPU
Kern nicht, wir brauchen jetzt 3 oder 16. So, ihr könnt diesen Server on the fly, oder
on the fly vielleicht nicht, ihr könnt den Server skalieren, ohne dass ihr ihn neu installieren
musst. Das muss ich jetzt bloß mal finden, wo das Ganze ist. Ich glaube bei, die hatten
ja nicht irgendwie einen Scale, Rescale, genau. Ein Add im Titel, aber ich habe hier oben.
So, ihr könnt den Server rescalen. Zum Beispiel, okay, wir haben jetzt so eine super geile,
beliebte Anwendung, dass wir sagen, hey, mit einem Kern kommen wir nicht hin, wir wollen
3 CPU Kerne. Jetzt kann ich das scaling, ohne dass ich es neu aufbauen muss, auf 3 Kerne,
aber jetzt muss man aufpassen. Wenn ich das jetzt, achso, ich muss den glaube ich, genau,
hier steht es nämlich schon drauf. Wenn ich die Festplatte mit skaliere, dann kann ich
jetzt nicht mehr downscalen. Also, normalerweise hat diese 3 Kernkiste, hat ja mehr SSD als
die 1 Kernkiste. Wenn ich aber die Festplatte mit skaliere, guck, wenn ich das jetzt zum
Beispiel raus nehme und das hier hoch skaliere, dann kann ich nie wieder downscalen, also ich
kann nur upscalen Festplatten Speicherplatz, aber nicht downscalen. Das heißt, wenn man
sowas macht, bietet es sich eigentlich immer an zu sagen, hey, mach nur CPU und RAM. Dann
kann ich nämlich, ich mach das jetzt, was habe ich für Schmerzen? Achso, ja, okay,
machen aus. So, dann kannst du das Ganze rescalen und nach ein paar Minuten hast du einen Server
mit 3 Kern. Und dann kannst du das auch wieder runterscalen. Wenn wir jetzt das gleiche gemacht,
also wenn wir das jetzt anders gemacht hätten, so wie ich das am Anfang machen wollte, dass
man nämlich sagt, man nimmt hier den da, weil ich ja 3 Kerne haben will, den kann ich nicht
downscalen. Der passt, ich glaube, der passt automatisch das Filesystem an, ja, aber halt
nicht runter, nur nach oben, weil runter kannst du ja schlecht wissen. Also wenn du das hier
jetzt auswählst, dann kannst du nie wieder downcrateen auf den da. Das heißt, was ich
empfehlen würde, wenn man nicht den Speicher braucht, wenn man den Speicher braucht, ist
wieder was anderes, aber dann kann man sich auch eine zusätzliche Storagebox dranhängen,
wenn man wirklich den Speicher braucht. Also wenn man wirklich Speicher braucht, kann man
sich zusätzlich hier auch noch welche erstellen, der übrigens gar nicht so teuer ist. Achso,
ich darf nicht, darf nicht mehr. Der gar nicht mal so teuer ist für das, dass es direkt
mountbarer Speicher ist. Die Storagebox kostet hier, oh, das ist nicht so teuer. 10TB 487
Euro im Monat. Also nicht so teuer im Vergleich zu anderen Anbietern. Wenn du bei Azure guckst,
bei Azure kostet das irgendwie, frag mich nicht, 20.000 Euro im Monat oder sowas. Das
ist nicht sonderlich teuer, 10TB 487 Euro. Das geht schon. Also wenn ich Zusatzspeicher
bräuchte, dann würde ich das wahrscheinlich hier drüber machen. Oder was ihr auch machen
könnt, das ist eine gute, was ihr auch machen könnt, wenn ihr wirklich sagt, hey, mir
ist das nichts und ich brauche auch die ganzen Features nicht, die man hier in der Cloud
hat. Ihr könnt natürlich immer noch auf die Server Aktion gehen und da eine richtig
fette Hardware-Kiste nehmen. Das ist dann aber nicht stündlich abgerechnet, das ist dann
monatlich so klassisch, wie man das Ganze kennt. Kann man auch machen. Aber ich würde
es wahrscheinlich so machen, wenn ich eine Kiste bräuchte mit Zusatzspeicher, dann würde
ich es wahrscheinlich hier drüber machen. Natürlich gibt es noch total abgedrehte Varianten.
Man könnte sich auch, ich sage nur, was man machen könnte, nicht, dass ich das jetzt unbedingt
empfehlen würde. Man kann natürlich auch sowas machen, wie man kauft sich hier eine
Kiste für 33 Euro im Monat mit dem Speicher, wobei das ist keine SSD, wir müssen erst
mal SSD. Da wird es nämlich schon ein bisschen teuer. Ihr kauft euch hier irgendwas, was
billiger ist und dann mauntet ihr das irgendwie über ISCSI oder was auch immer auf eure Kiste.
Kann man alles machen. Die einfachste Variante und auch vom Handling am einfachsten ist,
wenn ihr das hier drüber macht. Legt ihr einfach ein neues Volume an und wählt dann
bei der Server-Erstellung aus, dass das an die Kiste dran gehängt wird. Dann habt ihr
nämlich nicht dieses Rescale-Problem und das ist das, was ich jetzt zeigen will. Dann
habt ihr nicht dieses Rescale-Problem und ihr könnt jederzeit die Kiste auch wieder
kleiner skalieren, weil das ist wichtig, wenn man Geld sparen will. Jetzt kostet die Kiste
nämlich, also jetzt bezahlt ihr nämlich die Drei-Kern-Kiste, also jetzt bezahlt ihr gerade,
oder ich, besser ist ja mein Account, ich bezahle jetzt 8,21 Euro im Monat, einmal angenommen,
ich will jetzt wieder runter skalieren, weil ich weniger brauche, dann kann ich das machen,
dann gehe ich einfach wieder hier drauf, Rescale und gehe wieder runter auf ein Kern. Funktioniert
wunderbar, solange ich nicht, und das ist das, worauf ich raus will, solange ich nicht
die Festplatte mit scale. So, jetzt haben wir eine Ein-Kern-Kiste, darauf muss man achten,
das ist das, worauf ich jetzt raus will, lange Rede, kurzer Sinn. Also wenn ihr Zusatzspeicher
braucht, dann macht es über den Volume und lasst die Platte, die Systemplatte am besten
klein, wenn ihr hoch und runter skalieren wollt. Zum Beispiel hatte ich das so, nur mal so,
dass das gar nicht so unsinnig ist, den Preis-Champ hatte ich bei Release, weil ich nicht wusste,
weil ich nicht wusste, wie viele Leute drauf gehen, hatte ich zum Release mal hoch skaliert
auf 16 Kerne, einfach zum gucken, dass es auf jeden Fall nicht abkackt, wenn ich es
auf YouTube zeige, da habe ich es hochgestellt auf 16 Kerne und dann habe ich einen Tag später
wieder runter skaliert, jetzt läuft er glaube ich auf einem Triple-Core. Und das ist halt
schon preislich ein Unterschied, guck mal, 60 Euro im Monat zu 8,21 Euro. Wenn dein
Wendorf-Folder 1,8 Gigabyte hat, ist das nicht schlimm, dann machst du einfach einen Volume
und hängst es an. Guck, das kann ich nämlich machen, wenn ich jetzt Zusatzspeicher brauche,
sag ich okay, meine Anwendung braucht 100 Gigabyte, dann sag ich hier, ich brauche 100 Gigabyte
und hänge das an meinen Ubuntu-Surfer dran und dann kann ich das verwenden. So, aber
jetzt loggen wir uns mal drauf ein, kommt nämlich die erste Geschichte. Also, erstmal
der IP-Leak, null. Ja, machen wir es jetzt unter Windows oder Linux. Wir machen das jetzt
unter, wir machen es unter Windows. Nein, wir machen es unter, ich mache es mal unter
Windows. Vorher machen wir aber noch eine andere Sache, das ist nämlich ein neues Feature,
was die jetzt haben. Die bieten jetzt auch Firewalls an. Früher war das so, die Kiste
hatte eine Public IP und es war alles direkt erreichbar. Normalerweise ist das erstmal
nicht schlimm, weil es läuft ja aus SSH auf dem Server nix. Also sprich, was nicht gestartet
ist als Dienst, kannst du ja auch nötig angreifen. Aber die haben ein neues Feature, was ich
persönlich ganz praktisch finde. Kann man sagen, create Firewall und wir nehmen mal
die Standardregel. Die Standardregel ist übrigens gut gesetzt, Port 22. Chat, Preisfrage, was
ist das für eine Regel? Die ganzen Hacker-Mens unter uns wissen es natürlich. Also TCP Port
22 SSH, dass ich mich einlaufen kann auf das System und das und das Ping. Richtig. So,
das Ding heißt jetzt Firewall 1. Wir nennen es mal nicht Firewall 1, wir nennen es QtFW,
weil es für den Stream ist. So und das kannst du dann auch gleich anlegen bzw. davor stellen
vor die Kiste. Und was wir jetzt gemacht haben ist, jetzt gibt es nur noch Port 22 und Ping
auf den Server, alles andere kommt nicht durch. Darauf muss man natürlich auch achten, wenn
man dann einen Webserver anmacht, dann ist der erstmal nicht erreichbar. Ich finde das
eine gute Sache, das gibt es auch erst seit einem halben Jahr oder so, ist noch nicht
so lange her. Und vorher gab es das nicht. Andere Anbieter haben das schon eine Weile,
aber was ich bei denen cool finde, ist es halt easy zu bedienen. Die Firewalls kosten
glaube ich noch nicht mal was. Ich glaube die sind kostenlos. Also es gibt eigentlich
keinen Sinn das nicht zu verwenden, vielleicht kostet es später mal was. Ist auf jeden Fall
eine sinnvolle Geschichte. Man könnte auch UFW oder sonst was anmachen, aber in dem Fall
finde ich es ganz praktisch, du musst dich nicht selbst darum kümmern. Genau, für die
eigentlichen Server, z.B. die die du über die Serverauktion kaufst, gibt es das schon
eine Weile, aber im Cloud Interface gibt es das erst seit einem halben Jahr noch nicht
mal. Ich glaube es gibt es erst seit 2-3 Monaten, das ist relativ neu. Ansonsten wir haben ja
schon mal vor einer Weile ein paar Linuskisten eingerichtet im Stream, da habe ich immer
UFW angemacht, das kannst du dir jetzt eigentlich sparen. Zumal du dich hier mit halt auch davor
schützt, dass du selbst Mist baust. Zum Beispiel, ich hatte ja hier das Problem für meinen
Preisecrawler, der muss ja Webseiten crawlen und Webseiten mögen das nicht so sehr gecrawlt
zu werden, deswegen bin ich über einen Proxy gegangen. Proxy mit 10 Ausgangs-IPs. Und da
habe ich auch den Fehler, ich habe es ein bisschen zu spät gemerkt, ich habe auch einen
Squid installiert und das ich automatisch gestartet habe, da hatte ich einfach mal Port 3128 offen
im Internet. Ist was, was man eigentlich nicht haben will und um so eine Sache vorzubeugen,
UFW an oder Firewall vor der Kiste an. Damit einem sowas nicht passiert. So, aber nachdem
die Kiste angelegt ist, jetzt kommen wir mal zu der eigentlichen Geschichte. Ja gut, du
kannst den Squid auch konfigurieren, aber wenn du ihn installierst, startet er mit Standard-Config
und ohne ACLs. Wobei das stimmt gar nicht. Das stimmt gar nicht. Ich glaube die Standard-Config
hat sogar eine ACL drin, die nur Localhost erlaubt. Was auch immer. Es ist zumindest
nicht verkehrt, die Firewall davor einzuschalten, weil wenn man nicht aufpasst, hast du nicht
aus Versehen irgendwas im Internet hängen. UFW taugt was, ja. Das ist absolut in Ordnung.
UFW würde ich auch immer einschalten. Jetzt in dem Fall spare ich es mir. Aber gut, also.
Server angelegt, ein Kern hat nicht so viel. Das erste was man macht ist, man kopiert die
IP und jetzt gehen wir mal auf eine Konsole. Wir machen es jetzt einmal initial mit Linux
und danach machen wir es mit Windows. Also gehen wir mal hier auf unser Terminal. SSH
und add, einloggen. Hat er mit der Firewall irgendwie Mist gebaut? Oder ist die Kiste
aus oder? Die Russen sind schon am Start. Nein, ich glaube da stimmt irgendwas. Irgendwas
habe ich verkehrt gemacht. Dadurch, dass ich noch nicht mal pingen kann, da stimmt irgendwas
nicht. Jaja, da ist die Kiste. Wartet mal. Zack. Es ist Beta Firewalls. Ich mach das mal
wieder weg. Wie detaille ich denn die Firewall überhaupt jetzt? Hier irgendwie, ne? Weg.
Resources. So. Ah, ok. Es ist Beta. Es ist Beta. Ich habe eigentlich eine SSH-Regel drin
gehabt. Probieren wir das noch mal aus. Vielleicht habe ich auch die Regeln falsch gemacht. Eigentlich
ist die Regel ok. Jetzt geht es auch. What the fuck? Was hat er für Schmerzen jetzt?
Ah, ok. Alles klar. Jetzt funktioniert es. Wunderbar. Zumindest man sieht, die Firewall
macht, was sie soll. Das war fast nicht mehr erreichbar gewesen. Wunderbar. Na gut, also
wir haben jetzt die Kiste. Firewall davor. Wir können auch gleich mal ausprobieren,
ob die Firewall funktioniert. Wir machen gleich mal einen Portscan und machen dort was auf.
Also, jetzt mal zurück. Wieder Linux für Noobs. Also das erste, was man machen sollte
ist, oder wie soll ich sagen. Man kann sich darüber streiten, was besser ist. Key-Authentifizierung
oder Passwort. Ja, ausreichend langes Passwort ist sicherlich sicher genug, würde ich mir
keine Gedanken machen. Aber Key-Authentifizierung hat den Vorteil, man braucht kein Passwort
mehr einzugeben. Also ich würde eigentlich immer Key-Authentifizierung machen. SSH-Port
ändern mache ich nicht. Das ist mir zu blöd. So. Das heißt, normalerweise funktioniert
das folgendermaßen. Wir machen das jetzt einmal manuell und dann machen wir es über
das Hetzner Webfrontend, dass man das nur einmal einrichten muss. Niemals Passwort,
warum nicht? Wenn das Passwort ausreicht und lang ist, hackermantelt ist auch keiner. So,
ich gucke mal kurz in meine E-Mails. Ich würde auch immer Key-Authentifizierung machen, aber
aus Bequemlichkeitsgründen. Haben wir nicht sogar letztes Video von einem Secureteam angeguckt?
Da hat genau das gleiche gesagt. Wenn das Passwort lang genug ist, macht euch nicht
so viele Gedanken. Aber es ist einfach angenehmer. Ach du Scheiß ist das Passwort lang. Ich kann
das nicht copy-pasten, weil ich einen Clipboard-Manager an habe und ich das dann in der History
stehen habe. Das will ich nicht. Das Passwort ist so lang. Viel Spaß beim Brute-Forcen.
Good luck, have fun. So. Ach guck mal, man muss sogar das Passwort beim First Login ändern.
Das ist gut. Das finde ich nice. Okay, Big Brain Time. Sekunde, Sekunde. Lass mal in
mich gehen. Passwort. Nicht eins, zwei, drei, vier, fünf, sechs. Lass mal kurz in mich
gehen. Was nehme ich denn? So, perfekt. Oh nein, ich muss den Scheiß noch mal eingeben.
Painz-Champ, Painz-Champ. Nur ein Passwort. Okay, noch mal. Also was ich euch zeigen will
ist Passwort-Authentifizierung ist Painz-Champ. Ich glaube, man sieht es jetzt schon. Man
kriegt Anfälle, wenn man Passwort-Authentifizierung mit langen Passwörtern macht. Ich mach das
jetzt nur einmal der Form halber, dass ihr seht, wie man es von Hand machen kann. Danach
machen wir es über das Hetzner Webinterface. Also. Wobei eigentlich könnte ich jetzt sogar
einen Clipboard-Manager packen, weil ich muss es ja eh ändern. Egal. Okay, New Password.
Wunderbar. So, wir sind eingeloggt. Perfekt. Ja klar, es kann mit Key-Sicherer sein, aber
ich keine Ahnung, ob das in letzter Zeit Probleme hat mit Passwort-Authentifizierung. Prinzipiell
würde ich sagen, wenn das Passwort lang genug ist, sollte man sich nicht so viele Gedanken
machen. Aber es hat aus ganz anderen Kunden Vorteile, Key-Authentifizierung zu nehmen,
weil es einfacher ist. Also, das ist Einloggen auf dem Linux-System mit Passwort. Ihr seht
schon, es ist ziemlich eklig, wenn man jedes Mal das Passwort eingeben muss. Was man machen
kann ist, man muss sich ein SSH-Key generieren. Das geht folgendermaßen. SSH, SSH-Key-Gen.
Das machen wir jetzt doch gleich mal auch unter Windows. Und da generiert das ein Schlüsselpaar,
ein Public-Key und ein Private-Key. Den Private-Key, das sollte man des, ähm, was? No. Monkeys.
Neues, neues Anlegen, Alter. Okay, wir wollen IDSA2 haben. Eine Passphrase. Passphrase ist
für Noobs. Also, das mit Private-Key sollte man auch wirklich ernst nehmen. Also, es gibt
dann hier Keys drinnen, die ich euch den Inhalt nicht zeigen werde, weil ich mein Private-Key
nicht leaken will. Und das solltet ihr auch niemals machen. Der Private-Key sollte private
bleiben. Das bedeutet, diese Keys, die das Ding eben, die das jetzt generiert hat, also
das hat er jetzt generiert. Idee, äh. Hä? Ach. Ich hab den Pfad nicht eingegeben. Okay,
ist wurscht, geht so genauso. Der hat zwei Keys generiert. IDSA2-Pub und IDSA, das ist
der Private-Key. Den dürft ihr niemand zeigen. Nicht copy-pasten und sonst wie. Wenn es irgendwo
ein Formular gibt, wo drinnen steht, hier Key einfügen, dann ist damit immer, es sei
denn es ist ein Scammer, dann ist damit immer der Public-Key gemeint. Den Public-Key könnt
ihr zeigen. Das ist überhaupt kein Problem. Den könnt ihr zeigen, den könnt ihr kopieren,
könnt ihr machen, was ihr lustig seid. Den Public-Key ist Public. Den Private-Key, das
ist da, worum es geht. Ich hab's im falschen Ordner, äh, ich hab's im falschen Ordner
angelegt. Ich move das mal kurz. Ja, jetzt ist der Kram da. So. Ähm. Und was man jetzt
machen kann, ist folgendes. Wenn man sich die Keys generiert hat, gibt es zwei Möglichkeiten.
Ich zeig's jetzt nur noch mal, der Formular, wie es von Hand funktioniert. Also, man kann
sich einloggen auf dem System, aktuell nur mit Passwort. Hat er denn für Schmerzen immer
zwischendurch? So, was man jetzt machen kann, ist ssh-copy-id. Was das macht, ist, ihr müsst
euch jetzt einmal noch einloggen mit Passwort und dann kopiert das euren Public-Key auf
den Server in ein spezielles File und beim Login guckt er danach, ob der Private-Key
von euch zu dem Public-Key passt, der auf dem Server hinterlegt ist und dann dürft ihr
euch ohne Passwort einloggen. Was jetzt passiert, ist folgendes. Ich log mich als root ein,
hier in ssh ist noch nix drinne oder authorized keys ist drinne und in dieses File schreibt
der jetzt meinen Public-Key rein. So, ich melde mich jetzt mal an. So, Key ist drauf
kopiert und wenn ich mich jetzt einlogge, ah, der benutzt den falschen Key, ok. Guckt,
der schreibt jetzt auch, nee, welchen Key hat er denn jetzt dahin kopiert? Welchen Key
hat er denn jetzt dahin kopiert? Ok, wir probieren es mal aus. Weiß nicht, was der jetzt verwendet
ist. Punkt ssh. Was hab ich, ich hab 30 Milliarden Keys, Alter. GDR ist es nicht. How to sich
aussperren, ausgesperrt bin ich nicht. Übrigens, wenn man solche Dinger macht, lasst immer,
lasst immer ne zweite Session auf. Welchen hab ich denn jetzt genommen? Ah, ok, alles
ok. DSA, ja, der Key ist 5 Jahre alt oder so. Also, ihr seht, ich kann mich ohne Passwort
einloggen, wenn man den richtigen Key nimmt. Warum das jetzt bei mir nicht funktioniert,
das ist folgendes, wobei eigentlich sollte das funktionieren. IP liegt, oh nein. Ich
hab hier mehrere Keys und anscheinend wusste er grad nicht, welchen er verwenden soll,
aber ok. Normalerweise habt ihr da nur einen und dann funktioniert's. Wir machen das jetzt
auch gleich unter Windows, dann klappt das. So, wenn man den Key angibt, dann funktioniert
das wunderbar. Ich kann mich jetzt ohne Passwort einloggen. Jo. Normal probiert er durch, ich
weiß nicht, was er für Schmerzen hat. Gut, das erste, was man macht, wenn man auf so
ne Kiste kommt, ist erstmal ein Update und alle Pakete updaten. Normalerweise probiert
er nacheinander alle durch, aber es hat nicht funktioniert. Lass mal kurz gucken.
Die Rechte sollten auch passen, dass das beim Public Key stört ihn eigentlich nicht. Keine
Ahnung. Weiß nicht, ob das damit... Wie gesagt, normalerweise probiert er den Kram durch.
Juckt ihn nicht, juckt ihn nicht. Ist ihm egal. So. Zumindest wir machen jetzt erstmal
ein Update und danach machen wir alle Pakete. So huge schnell ist es grad nicht. So, danach
upgraden wir mal alle Pakete. Das ist die erste Amtshandlung, die man eigentlich immer
machen sollte. Machst du irgendwann mal Fitness-Videos? Na klar. Ich bin der perfekte Fitness-Coach
auf jeden Fall. Da gibt es bestimmt auf YouTube keinen besseren als mich. Vielleicht weil
Passwort Osno an ist. Ich weiß nicht. Zumindest machen wir das jetzt eh anders. Ich zeige
euch das mal hier. Authorized Keys. Also dass das auch wirklich funktioniert. Guck, Max
Ed Poggers. Das war ein Public Key, den ich euch eben gezeigt habe. Also das funktioniert.
Jetzt kann ich mich einloggen. Das hat den Vorteil, ihr braucht nicht diesen ganzen Mist
jedes Mal 20-stelliges Passwort eintippen und sonst was. Also deswegen ist Key-Authentifizierung
schon mal sinnvoll. Und dann macht ihr jetzt folgendes, wenn ihr den SSH Key angelegt habt.
Wir machen das mit Windows jetzt gleich nochmal. Eigentlich wollte ich es ja unter Windows zeigen.
Ich lösche den Server jetzt, weil wir legen das jetzt nochmal an mit Keys. Wollt euch
nur mal zeigen, wie das von Hand geht. So, wir löschen die Kiste jetzt nochmal und jetzt
Pains Champ. Machen wir das Ganze nochmal unter Windows. Jetzt wird es eklig. So, mal schauen.
Wie machen wir das unter Windows? Also Windows 11, wir sind Bleeding Edge. Terminal auf.
Also Terminal auf. WSL auf, ist ja im Prinzip auch ein Ubuntu. Geht das auch mit PowerShet?
Nee, wir machen das nicht mit PowerShet. Ich kann mir das nicht gehen mit PowerShet,
vergesst. Aber wir machen es unter Windows. Die meisten Leute machen es unter Windows.
Und eine Sache, von der ich euch jetzt gleich mal abraten will, ist Putty. Putty ist so
eines der Programme, die, weiß ich, jeder kennt Putty. Gibt es jemanden im Chat, der
nicht Putty kennt? Putty hat glaube ich jeder schon mal gesehen. Aber ich finde Putty ist
mega Pains Champ. Ich zeige es euch mal für alle, die es noch nicht gesehen haben. Aber
wir verwenden kein Putty. Das sage ich gleich dazu. Putty ist das, was man jahrelang unter
Windows für SSH verwendet hat. Das machen wir aber nicht mehr. Das machen wir aber nicht
mehr. Putty ist eklig. Putty ist im Endeffekt ein Session Manager für unterschiedliche
Geschichten. Du kannst Tellnet machen, du kannst Serial machen. Dafür ist das gut. Für SSH
muss ich sagen, ich finde es ein bisschen eklig, weil du lernst im Endeffekt nicht,
was du machst, sondern du klickst in Putty rum. Und Putty braucht auch für SSH Keys
ein anderes Format und sowas. Es ist einfach irgendwie sehr, wie soll ich sagen, so kontraproduktiv
Putty zu verwenden. Dazu kommt, dass das eigentliche Fenster von Putty auch richtig
eklig zu bedienen ist. Das Minischrift, klar, das kannst du anpassen, das Copy und Pasten
ist eklig. Ich glaube, jeder, der das verwendet hat, hat schon mal das Problem gehabt, dass
er in Putty auch so sehen, zwei Seiten Copy Pasted hat, auf rechtsklick, finde ich eklig.
Was ich schöner finde unter Windows ist folgendes. Wenn ihr egal, ob ihr Windows 10 oder Windows
11 habt, installiert euch WSL und installiert euch das neueste Windows Terminal. Dann sieht
das so aus, wie bei mir. Der User muss natürlich cuteweep93 heißen, anders funktioniert es
nicht. Und dann habt ihr quasi einen Ubuntu unter Linux. Das, finde ich, ist die angenehmste
Variante, wenn ihr keine Linux-VM oder keine Linux-Kiste habt. Jetzt komme ich noch mal
ganz schnell chat, weil ich schon seit drei Stunden sage, ich beantworte gleich noch mal
schnell chat. Ubuntu, habe ich unter Linux gesagt? Ich meine Ubuntu unter Windows. Ubuntu
unter Windows. Installiert euch WSL 2 und das aktuelle Windows Terminal. Das Schöne
unter Windows 11 wird sein, dass es schon dabei ist. Also du kannst unter Windows 11 mit einem
Kommando WSL installieren und du kannst, ich glaube, du hast das Windows Terminal sogar
schon mit dabei installiert. Ja, das ist auch ein weiterer Vorteil, WSL zu verwenden, weil
dann hast du das ganze Ubuntu Zeug dabei. Schauen wir mal kurz Questions durch. Ja und
weiter. Also hat sich das jetzt auf Putty bezogen? Ja, aber ein paar Putty hast du beispielsweise
das ekliche Terminal Fenster, in dem du dich laufend vercopy pastest und andere Probleme
hast und keine Sonderzeigen gescheit kannst. Und das Schlimmste ist Putty. Wisst ihr was
das Schlimmste an Putty ist, Leute? Soll ich? Ich zeige euch mal das Schlimmste an Putty.
Kann man lokale Session irgendwie aufmachen? Geht das? Gibt es das irgendwie lokale Session
mit Putty? Geht das irgendwie? Raw? Keine Ahnung. Roast. Ich weiß sowieso nicht. Was
auch immer. Warum Putty Paint Jam ist, Putty kann keine Emojis schon mal. Also allein schon
deswegen sollte das 2021 raus sein. Terminal, was keine Emojis kann, ist outdated, overrated
debated. Weg damit. Gute Frage. Ich bin mir nicht ganz sicher, was du meinst. Meinst du
irgendwie Protection gegen irgendwelche? Was ist Burst für dich? Dns Amplification oder
jede Verbindung erstellen oder was ist Burst? Ja, wie gesagt, da bin ich wahrscheinlich
echt der Beste für Fitness Videos. Da hat die Welt drauf gewartet. Ich habe doch letztens
schon ein Fitness Video gemacht. Guckt mal. Hier Fitness Video. Moment Moment. Okay. Nein,
das haben wir da nicht. Du hast eine Kiste, die hat reservierte Hardware und das war's.
Du kannst die skalieren. So guckt mal hier. Ich habe noch hier letztens Fitness. Hier
Fitness Video. Guck mal hier. Also wenn das nicht als Fitness Video reicht, dann weiß
ich auch nicht. Also mehr kann man sich doch wirklich nicht nicht wünschen von einem Fitness
Video. Nee, stell's. Sazubi Video kommt nächste Woche am Montag oder Dienstag. Ich hab das
schon aufgenommen. Und ihr seht, in welcher huge Geschwindigkeit ich mich hier bewege.
Und ich schwanke mit dem Telefon. Also gerade den Berg runter hier, das saust ja richtig
ab. 2,9K zu 8. Das Beste ist immer noch die Schneemänner. Guck mal. Erkennt ihr das?
Jep Kok Schneemänner. So, jetzt sagen wir mal zur eigentlichen Sache zurück. Also ihr
installiert das aktuelle Windows Terminal und WSL. Dann habt ihr den Kram wie ich.
Das heißt, ihr könnt jetzt das im Prinzip machen wie unter wie unter Linux. Es ist ja
ein Linux, aber halt unter Windows. So, das heißt, wir machen SSH. Ich hab das noch nie
gemacht, muss ich ehrlich sagen, unter unter unter Windows mit WSL. Kann man einfach so
Key gerne machen? Jawoll, jawoll, jawoll. Also wir generieren den Key. Das heißt, hier
SSH ist der ganze Kram am Start. Jetzt, dass wir das nicht immer von Hand machen müssen.
Was nennen wir den Key? Copy Pasten. Wie Copy Pasten? Mal den Geschalt aus dem Windows Terminal
raus. Wir Copy Pasten uns den Key. Und nun, jetzt kommt der Trick, jetzt kommt Trick 17.
Wenn man bei Hetzer einen Server anlegt, kann man auswählen, welchen Key man verwenden will.
Und wohlgemerkt, ich sag's hier nochmal, Public Key, Public Key. Ihr kopiert da nicht den
Private Key rein. Ich hatte das auf der Arbeit schon. Wir machen's bei uns auf der Arbeit,
vielleicht bei so kleinen Exkurs, wir machen's auf der Arbeit so, dass wir nicht mehr SSH
Keys kopieren müssen und sonstige Geschichten. Wir haben eine CA, die stellt diese SSH Keys
aus, beziehungsweise signiert das. Und alles von dieser CA wird getrusted und man kann
sich einloggen. So. Und damit man das signieren kann, müssen einem die Leute ihren Key schicken.
So. Und ich hatte's mehr als einmal schon, dass die Leute mir ihren Private Key geschickt
haben. Das ist der Wahnsinn. Also. Und das sind eigentlich welche, die müssten's wissen.
Immer nur den Public Key schicken. Genau. Ppo G, Leute. Ppo G. Okay, so. Wir wollen
wieder die Cute FW als Fireball haben, da ist nur Ping und Port 22 auf. Und jetzt kommt
der eigentliche Nachpunkt. Okay, man sagt hier Add Key und kopiert das rein. Die sind
schon schlau genug mittlerweile, dass die erkennen, wenn Zeilenumbrüche drin sind. Ein beliebter
Fehler beim Kopieren von solchen Keys ist, dass hier Zeilenumbrüche drin sind, die das
Ganze kaputt machen. Man muss gucken, dass das alles in einer Zeile ist. Die hier bei
Hetzer sind so schlau, die formatieren es schon für euch richtig um. So. Add Key. So.
Dieser Key, den wollen wir automatisch hinzufügen für den Root User, wenn der Server angelegt
wird. Das passt. Alles klar. Zack. Anlegen. Create. Key League, MonkaS. Ja. So. Und wenn
die Kiste jetzt aufgebaut ist, dann müssen wir nichts anderes machen, außer uns einfach
einloggen und es wird direkt funktionieren, weil wir den richtigen SSH Key haben. Weiß
ich, was die Kisten für Schmerzen haben? Die brauchen immer ein bisschen, bis sie hoch
gefahren sind. So. Guckt. Zack. Login. Ohne Passwort. Aber wo würde man das bei seinem
eigenen Server machen? Das habe ich doch vor fünf Minuten erzählt, bevor wir das gemacht
haben über Hetzer. Du gehst in den, also wie du das auf deinem eigenen Server machst,
ist ganz einfach. Also im Prinzip so, wie ich es eben gezeigt habe, bevor wir das machen,
bevor wir das bei Hetzer gemacht haben. Deswegen habe ich es ja vorher von Hand gezeigt, wie
das funktioniert. Also. Du gehst in das Heimatverzeichnis des Users, als der du dich einloggen willst.
Ich zeige es dir hier drauf. In dem Fall ist es jetzt Root. Slash Root. Heimatverzeichnis
von Root. Who am I? Root. So. Und da im SSH-Verzeichnis gibt es eine Authorized Key Datei. Und da
kopierst du den Key rein. Deinen Public Key. Wohlgemerkt. Nicht den Public Key. Da kopierst
du deinen Public Key rein und dann kannst du dich einloggen ohne Passwort. Oder du benutzt,
was auch geht, SSH Copy ID. Dann macht er genau das gleiche für dich. Und das Schöne
ist, ab jetzt können wir uns immer einloggen ohne Passwort. Das ist der eigentliche Grund,
warum ich Key Authentifizierung versus Passwort Authentifizierung verwende. Mir geht es gar
nicht so sehr um die Sicherheit. Wenn das Root Passwort lang genug ist, habe ich damit
keine Probleme. Es ist einfacher. Es ist angenehmer. Und ihr seht, ihr könnt das auch ohne Probleme
machen unter Windows, wenn ihr PSL habt. So und jetzt kommen wir mal zu Putty. Was ich
nicht mehr verwende. Bei Putty hätte ich jetzt schon das Problem. Wie stelle ich Putty
mein SSH Key ein? Das finde ich nie und wenn ich es finde, stelle ich fest, dass Putty
die Keys in einem anderen Format brauchen. Es ist eklig. Leute, verwendet WSL verwendet
kein Putty. Es ist einfach angenehmer. WSL oder am besten habt ihr die Linux VM und macht
es da drüber. Achso. Ja übrigens, das kommt dann auch. Das sollte ich vielleicht auch
nochmal erwähnen. Ich habe mich vorhin mit dem Linux auf diesem Server eingeloggt und
in der Zwischenzeit habe ich den Server gelöscht und neu angelegt. Jetzt ist mein SSH so schlau
und sagt, hey guck mal, der Key vom Server hat sich ja geändert. Das heißt, vielleicht
hat jemand den Server übernommen oder was auch immer oder sich die IP übernommen und
möchte jetzt quasi vortäuschen jemand anderes zu sein. Deswegen meckert SSH, wenn du dich
einmal eingeloggt hast und baust den Server neu auf, dann sagt er, guck mal, der Server
hat sich geändert. Das kann man ignorieren. Die einfachste Variante ist das hier, aber
das sollte man nicht machen. Ich sag's nur mal, dass das geht. Das kann man machen. Da
kann man sagen, so nach dem Motto, Scheiß drauf ist mir egal. Das ist aber keine schöne
Variante. Die schönere Variante ist zu sagen, okay, warum ist das so? Ah ja klar, ich hab
meinen Server neu aufgebaut und dann macht man, das kann ich mir übrigens nie aus dem
Kopf merken. Was macht man an SSH? Keygen minus D oder sowas? Moment. Wie regelt du
das mit mehreren Servern? Was meinst du? Ist es minus D, Delete? Nee. Ach du, warte was?
Ich kann's mir immer nicht merken. Man kann auch einfach in die Datei gehen und das löschen,
das funktioniert genauso. Was war das denn jetzt nochmal? Oder war das? Ja ja, ich kann
die known hosts bearbeiten, das ist mir auch klar. Aber es gab doch ein Befehl dafür,
wie war der denn nochmal? Minus R? SSH Keygen minus R? Minus R klingt gut für Remove. Ohne
User. So und jetzt? Ja. Und jetzt sagt er, aha, was hat er? Alter, ich hab den total
durcheinander gemacht mit meinen komischen RSA Keys. Muss den Kram mal wieder löschen,
jetzt funktioniert's auch. Ach Quatsch, das ist ja der Windows User. Meine Güte ey.
Chet, ihr seid schuld. Das ist ja der Windows User, da hab ich den Keyer auf meiner Lieblingsgeschichte
gar nicht. Kann ja gar nicht funktionieren. Ich hab mir den Key, aber ihr seht, dass das
prinzipiell funktioniert. Ich hab den Keyer hier auf meiner Windows Kiste generiert, den
hab ich ja hier gar nicht. Das heißt, was ich hier versucht hab, ist mich auf den Server
einzuholen, wo ich keine Berechtigung drauf hab, das heißt RIP. So. Was macht ihr denn
jetzt? Jetzt kommt die Big Brain Frage. Was macht ihr denn jetzt, wenn ihr den Private
Key verloren habt? Stellt euch mal vor, euer Rechner kackt ab, wir haben keinen Backup
von eurem Private Key. Was macht ihr denn jetzt? Weinen. Weinen ist schon mal gut.
Also prinzipiell, wenn es sich um irgendwelche Verschlüsselungen handelt, habt ihr gelitten.
Also habt ihr irgendwas mit einem Key verschlüsselt, aber der Key ist weg, dann habt ihr gelitten.
Ich mein, kannst du auch mehr als einen Server mit dem Terminal nutzen? Na klar, das zeige
ich dir gleich. Das zeige ich dir gleich. Das machen wir gleich alles. So, aber nachdem
wir hier hier nichts verschlüsselt haben, haben wir noch die Möglichkeit, das bisschen,
ja wie soll ich sagen, zu zu recovern. Ja, können wir machen. Es gibt verschiedene Varianten.
Am besten ist, ihr verliert euren Key nicht. Das ist die einfachste Variante. Was ihr machen
könnt, ist folgendes. Ihr könnt die Server Konsole aufmachen und wenn ihr den Root Passwort
habt, könnt ihr euch darüber einloggen. Das funktioniert. Wenn ihr kein Root Passwort
habt, habt ihr auch Probleme. Das nächste, was ihr machen könnt, ist, ihr könnt den
Server neu starten, in das Boot Menü gehen und dort in Single User Mode booten. Das können
wir jetzt übrigens mal machen, wenn ihr das sehen wollt. Dort in Single User booten und
dann dort das Root Passwort ändern. Das geht. Ach ja, ihr könnt übrigens auch den Rescue
Mode verwenden. Da habe ich jetzt gar nicht dran gedacht. Ihr könnt auch den Rescue Mode
verwenden, den Hetzer eingebaut hat. Weiterer Vorteil von, man verwendet was, wo der Anbieter
sich Gedanken zugemacht hat. Ihr könnt auch einfach den Rescue Modus verwenden. Das geht
natürlich auch. Da habe ich jetzt nicht dran gedacht, aber wahrgenommen, das ging nicht.
Es wäre auch zu einfach, den Rescue Modus zu verwenden. Ich weiß nicht, ob ich euch
das über die Konsole zeigen kann, ob man ins Boot Menü kommt. Das könnt ihr übrigens
bei jedem x-beliebigen Linux System machen, solange es nicht verschlüsselt ist. Ich zeige
euch das mal. Es gilt bei jedem Linux Server, solange die Festplatte oder Krab nicht verschlüsselt
ist. Also wenn ihr das Root Passwort vergessen habt, oder wenn ihr nur SSH Login habt und
könnt euch nicht mehr darauf einloggen. Es gibt eine Möglichkeit, wo ihr jeden Linux
Server recovern könnt. Ihr startet das Ding neu, also ihr braucht physischen Axis auf
den, und ich habe zu langsam geklickt. Was muss man überhaupt gedrückt halten, um in
Krab zu kommen mittlerweile? Escape hemmern, ich hemmere einfach mal Escape. Früher war
es Shift? Ne, weiß gar nicht, ob das überhaupt... Ah ja, einfach nur Shift hemmern, alles klar.
Ich habe gerade Shift, E und Escape gehemmert, was war denn das Richtige jetzt? Ich habe
alles gedrückt. Alle. Ok, also was man machen kann ist folgendes, ich hoffe das funktioniert
überhaupt. Ich habe das nämlich unter Ubuntu ehrlich gesagt ewig nicht mehr gemacht. Einfach
Face Rollen über die ganze Tastatur, also jetzt seid ihr im Boot Manager, dann geht
ihr auf, oh ne, das ist der neue Krab. Fuck, ich weiß nicht mehr wo man das macht. Ähm,
ich glaube hier, hier, oh, oh, oh. Also, Leute ich weiß nicht ob es funktioniert, also was
man machen kann ist folgendes, man kann entweder ein S reinschreiben für Single User, ne 1,
oder man kann Single reinschreiben, oder man kann sagen init gleich bin sh. Keine Ahnung
ob das so funktioniert jetzt. Was der macht ist, der bootet dann nicht quasi das normale
Init System, sondern startet eine Shell und das war's. Ähm, ich hab keine Ahnung ob
ich das jetzt an der richtigen Stelle drin hab, wenn ich ehrlich bin. Wir probieren einfach
mal aus ob es funktioniert. SH ist nur ein Link zu Bash. Gut, aber Link geht auch. Ich
hab keine Ahnung ob es funktioniert. Wir probieren es jetzt einfach mal aus. Ok, Ctrl
X. Ähm, es hat, gleich sehen wir ob es funktioniert. Es hat, ähm,
keine Ahnung, hat nicht funktioniert wahrscheinlich. Ok, wisst ihr was, wir fragen einfach mal
Google was Google dazu sagt. Das hat jetzt übrigens nichts mit Linux für Einsteiger
zu tun, mich interessiert es einfach nochmal. Äh, Ubuntu, äh, init bin sh. Geht das noch?
Bin Bash muss man immer, bin sh muss doch auch funktionieren. Ich, ich probier's einfach
nochmal. Aber es kann echt sein, dass, dass der andere Syntax hat mittlerweile. Also früher
konntest du definitiv Single reinschreiben für Single User und unter Red Hat geht das
glaube ich heute noch. Ok, ist das, ist die Zeile überhaupt richtig wo ich hier so bin?
Ich mein das ist, das ist die Kernel Zeile. Die Kernel Zeile ist ja eigentlich das, das,
das Richtige, ne? So, passt eigentlich. Init, hat er vorher noch ein anderes Init? Init,
gleich. Mal gucken. Äh, ist wieder RIP. Ok, keine Ahnung. Keine Ahnung, dann weiß ich
nicht wie es funktioniert. Da müsste ich jetzt eine Weile suchen und es ist ziemlich
langweilig. Von der Idee her geht das aber so. Muss nur die richtige Syntax rauskriegen.
Ne. Macht nicht. Ist egal. Ich starte jetzt richtig und gut ist. Vielleicht hab ich's
auch geprickt irgendwie jetzt. Ist komplett RIP. Ne. Ne, scheint, scheint zu funktionen.
Zumindest merke, es geht. Du kannst jeden LinksX beliebigen Linux Server, solange der
nicht die Festplatte verschlüsselt hat, kannst du das Root Passwort resetten. Wenn du die
richtige Syntax für diesen Crap kennst, was ich hier gerade machen wollte. Ein RW for
bin bash. Aber wenn der nicht Read-Write ist, dann hätte er zumindest weiterbooten
müssen und mir sagen, dass es nicht funktioniert. Ich wette es geht immer noch nicht. Ok, einmal
probieren wir es noch, Chat. Einmal. Hämmern, hämmern, hämmern. Oh, ich geh zu spät.
Nochmal. Ah, yes. Also, Chat, ich mach jetzt was ihr sagt und wir wissen ja, bekanntlicherweise
hat der Chat immer recht, wenn es heißt, wenn der Chat jetzt falsch liegt, würde das automatisch
dazu führen, weil 100% Recht bedeutet er immer recht. 99,periode 9 Recht bedeutet nicht immer
recht. Also, damit ist das, der Chat immer recht hat vorbei, wenn der Chat jetzt nicht,
einmal nicht recht hat. So, was davor ist ein RO? Oh, ach da. Ja, das ist aber eigentlich
nicht schlimm. Der würde mir dann, das ist nicht schlimm. Normalerweise ist es immer
Read-Only und dann machst du ein Remount-Route. Ähm, Patrick hat Recht, lul. Jetzt wird hier
richtig Big-Prain-Time. Normalerweise ist es egal, du remountest das neu. Äh, Read-Write.
Das wird jetzt auch nicht funktionieren. Ich weiß nicht, was ich verkehrt mache. Keine
Ahnung. Da müsste ich jetzt ein bisschen googeln, aber ich hab keinen Bock drauf. Muss ich
vielleicht hier, 1, 2, 1, 2 dahinten? Neue Zeile vielleicht? Ach, keine Ahnung. Ne. Yip,
vorbei. Egal, wir lassen das jetzt. Das ist total unwichtig. Ich wollte es euch bloß
zeigen und es funktioniert jetzt nicht, dann ist ok. RIP Chat, Chat hat nicht Recht. Gut,
weiter, weiter im Text, ja. Also, gehen wir mal wieder auf Windows. Ah, wir haben gebootet
und ich mach den Greppel mal zu. Ok, gehen wir mal auf Windows, loggen uns ein, auf unsere
Linux-Kiste sind eingeloggt. So, das erste was wir machen ist, und jetzt um mal die Frage
beantworten von Freak288, kann man das mit mehreren Servern machen? Ja, das ist kein
Problem. Du kannst sogar, und jetzt kommt gleich der richtige Big-Prain-Modus, du kannst
sogar mehrere Sachen gleichzeitig auf dem gleichen Server machen. So, aber das erste,
Pakete updaten, Pakete updaten. So, und jetzt zeige ich dir mal, dass du das auf mehreren
Servern machen kannst. Wir legen jetzt einfach mal mehrere Server an. So, Add Server, nehmen
wir nochmal, kleinste Kiste, wieder die Firewall davor, wir nehmen unseren Key, dass wir uns
direkt einloggen können, Create. So, warten wir bis das ganze erstellt ist, und... Ah,
habe ich jetzt den Helsinki einerstellt, oder was? Ah, jetzt habe ich den Helsinki einerstellt,
ok, meinetwegen. Kann ich auch mitleben. Upgrade is overrated. So, wir haben Update gemacht,
dann machen wir ein Upgrade, Upgrade. Also, Update, das Farbschema von Windows ist eklig,
ich gehe doch wieder auf Linux gleich rüber. Update, guckt nur nach, ob es neue Updates
gibt, Upgrade macht das eigentlich Update. Muss man sich auch erstmal merken. So, und
jetzt zeige ich euch mal, dass du mehrere Sachen gleichzeitig machen kannst. Du kannst
erstmal, die Noob-Variante ist mehrere Tabs aufmachen. So, die Pro-Variante ist folgendes,
so macht man das jetzt. Emacs auf, mehrere gesplitterte Sessions, SSH, Root Add, Helsinki
Server. So, und hier oben, Root Add, was haben wir denn da? Schon wieder vergessen. Schau
ich nochmal aus. Ja, Copy Paste in der Windows-Shell ist auch Paints-Champ. Guck mal. Und schon
bist du auf beiden Servern in der gleichen Shell eingeloggt. Jetzt hier oben sind wir
in Nürnberg und hier unten sind wir in Helsinki. Alpili, ja, ich kann mitleben. Funktioniert.
Was noch cooler ist, man kann sogar, mal angenommen, ihr habt jetzt einen Server in Helsinki, ja,
ich will jetzt aber keine Windows-Terminal-Geschichten zeigen. Was sogar noch cooler ist, mal angenommen,
ihr wollt jetzt auf beiden Servern das gleiche machen, dann könnt ihr sogar, Set, Sync,
ne, ohje, Set, Sync, Syncronize, ne. Yes. Ach meine Güte, ich verwende den Kram so selten,
das weiß ich doch alles aus dem Kopf nicht. Ok, wir gucken jetzt nach, wie das funktioniert.
Ich muss da gucken, wie es funktioniert. Also, Syncronize Paints hab ich doch gemacht. ZW,
nicht LulW, ZW. Alles klar. ZW, Syncronize Paints, yes. Und jetzt, guck mal hier, jetzt
mach ich auf beiden Servern exakt das gleiche. Einmal in Nürnberg und einmal in Helsinki.
Wir tippen jetzt genau das gleiche, Hacker-Mans, auf beiden Servern, obwohl die an komplett
unterschiedlichen Orten auf der Welt stehen. Ja, so schöne Sachen kann man damit machen.
Ist jetzt glücklicherweise nicht Windows-Only, sondern geht in jedem Terminal. Ist aber eine
praktische Sache. Wollte ich euch aber eigentlich erst später zeigen, deswegen werd ich jetzt
mal Folgendes machen, weil mir Windows auf den Sack geht. Ich schmeiß die Kisten weg.
Wir erstellen jetzt zwei neue und dann zeige ich euch, wie man die Sachen einrichtet, bzw.
was man noch machen sollte. Aber Freak288, ich denke, das sollte deine Frage beantworten,
ob man mehrere Sachen aus einem Terminal machen kann. Ja, kann man und wenn du das auf dem
Server machst, ist F. Da ist Vodafone. Vodafone, please. Vodafone, please. Hatten wir ja gestern
schon, dass sie erst die rumspacken. Na ja. Übrigens, für die richtig krassen Hacker-Mans
gibt es ein Kommando-Zeilen-Tool. Ich kann euch das jetzt auch noch mal zeigen. Es gibt
ein Kommando-Zeilen-Tool für die Hetzner Cloud zum Server anlegen. Das ist die richtige
Hacker-Mans-Variante. H-Cloud-Server-Create. Hier, guckt euch das mal an. Bam. Ohne Webinterface
klicken. Waiting for... Okay, alles klar. Bam. Guck, Server, da ist er. Cac-Wait. Und
noch einer. Ah nee, Moment, Cac-Wait gibt es ja schon. Cac-Wait 2. Das brinde das Passwort
in die Shell. Ja, aber ich habe einen Key ausgewählt. Das ist vor allem ein Workstation.
Guck, wir haben zwei Systeme jetzt. Mit diesen IPs. Und das haben wir jetzt über die Shell
angelegt. Im Prinzip genau das gleiche, wie wenn ich über das Webinterface angelegt
hätte. SSH, Root-Add, den da. Bam. Yes. Und SSH, Root-Add, den da. Sondern mit zwei
Kisten. Und ja, man sieht, man kann das alles wunderbar parallel laufen lassen. Das ist
überhaupt kein Problem. Und ob ihr es über Kommandozeile anlegt oder über das Webinterface
anlegt, ist eigentlich ziemlich egal. So, wenn ihr jetzt in die Delungskiste angelegt
habt, das wichtigste, worauf ich nochmal hinweisen will, ist folgendes. Macht das direkt im
Setup mit eurem Key. Macht das direkt mit eurem Key im Setup. Ihr könnt auch mehrere
auswählen, überhaupt kein Problem. Macht das mit eurem Key, dann müsst ihr nie irgendwelche
20-stelligen Root-Passwörter eingeben. Und was auch von Vorteil ist, dem Servern ordentliche
Namen zu geben. Also erstmal Paket-Update machen. Die Mario-Musik ist sehr entspannt.
So, Paket-Update. Wie gesagt, Update, guckt, ob es Pakete, neue Pakete gibt. Upgrade, update
die Dinger. So, und eine Sache, die man auch immer machen sollte, wenn man das zumindest
das erste Mal machen und bei jedem Colonel-Update Rebooten. Weil, sonst ist der neue Colonel
nicht geladen. Kann ich euch zeigen. Wenn es Colonel-Update gibt, immer Rebooten. Wenn
es zeitlich gerade hinpasst. Also ich würde jetzt nicht Rebooten, wenn ihr gerade einen
Minecraft-Server hostet, wo gerade 20 Leute drauf spielen. Dann würde ich vielleicht
nicht unbedingt Rebooten, wenn da 20 Leute sind. Lösch den Server besser schnell. Warum?
Oh, Vodafone, please. Vodafone, please.
Oh, Vodafone, please.